[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
baseball coming up from the nation's
capital welcome to the mlb game of the
week pregame show presented by global
citizen vax live the braves have won
four or five games versus the nationals
this season the team is five games under
500 versus all other teams but all five
games have come in d.c beautiful day for
baseball in washington and it's been so
much fun to watch this guy hit rauld
acuna for the first time in his career
winning player of the month for the
atlanta braves actually the second
consecutive break to win because freddie
freeman won september of last year he's
been absolutely scorching for this
offense leading in virtually every
single offensive category he'll be
facing johnny lester that's right one
year five million dollar contract with
the nationals he's being opposed by
another veteran lefty who signed a
one-year deal also looking for his first
win with his new team that would be drew
smiley who signed a one-year 11 million
deal with the atlanta braves
and with that a formal welcome in here
inside studio 42 alongside mike lowell
and adnan burke how about this meeting
of the minds right meaning of the minds
at the plate absolutely before we get
into the actual baseball action mike how
about a say hey to the say hey kid
willie mays 90 years of age amazing he's
the oldest living baseball player in the
hall of fame and we're almost up to may
25th it's gonna be 70 years since his
debut what do you think of when i say to
you as a former player willie mays well
easily one of the all-time greats you
know i think when you look at his
numbers the numbers speak for themselves
but what stands out to me 24-time
all-star that's 24 seasons just to play
that which is which is truly amazing but
you know we did mlb network did a
feature on him which i believe we can
see on our in our youtube page
and it was pretty cool to see that he
not only was a baseball player he was an
entertainer like he he was aware of that
and you know the basket catches and the
flare and the the the dynamic of being
able to steal bases and take the extra
base i think there was such an extra
intangible that willie mays brought to
the table that i think when you say hey
i went to go see a baseball game and
this guy caught my eye and it was
something that you know for that
generation i wasn't born at the time
sure they never forget you know i hear
the stories that my dad said when i
would see willie mays he was by far the
best player on the field so i think
that's something that really stands out
yeah i love those old videos i mean that
that catch off the bat at vickwortz in
the 54 world series they'll never get
old and like you said the flamboyance of
it along with the natural talent it's
amazing to see happy birthday to willie
mays all right we're going to talk about
the braves and the nationals before we
dive into acuna let's check out the
highlights from last night
so now they walk freddie freeman and go
righty righty with ozuna ace is loaded
two down and he swings the first one and
launches it to right field harrison back
turns it is gone a grand slam frozuna on
the first pitch brings up william
contreras who sparked the big rally in
the third inning as contreras 3-0 count
got the green light he lifts one to
center field contreras to the deepest
part of the ballpark first career home
run for william contreras
that's right contreras to brother wilson
contreras the chicago cubs because
travis darnold is out right now for the
braves so these are the nla standings
some people thought it might be the best
division in baseball instead you've got
four of the five teams under 500 but
it's tight the marlins are just two
games out very last the philly's
currently in first and the braves and
nasa's the teams you're seeing today
just one and a half games back i
mentioned ronald cuny at the top mike
guy's having a sensational season we've
always known he's been a great player
but what are you seeing specifically
from this year well it seems like he's
just putting everything together we're
going to take it we're going to take a
look at what he does exceptionally well
it's not just one thing i mean this guy
has a combination of power and speed and
as we take a look here i hope uh we're
going to see the numbers are staggering
you know he leads the league in runs
home runs slugging ops and by the way
he's 23 years old yeah he's a baby so
you see here we knew the power as a
prospect the power was one of the things
that really jumped out oh this young kid
has tons of power but what's special to
me is that's a ball that's up and away
to be able to get on top of that and
still hit it hard enough to left field
is pretty impressive here this is a
change up below the strike zone kind of
outer third to have the discipline to
stay on it and to take it out to right
field you know not many guys have that
ability and then he brings a little he
brings a little flair you know he's
exciting he can run the bases this is a
very underrated uh i guess
quality that he has i think he caught a
little bit of flak because you know the
hustle in the playoffs a couple years
ago
maybe his reputation was stained in that
sense but he's putting it all together
he's a guy his extra base rate is
extremely high which means he can go
from first to third score on balls like
this jason hayward is one of the best
outfield arms in the big leagues they
cut the ball he made this look easy so
that ability to stretch doubles into
triples score on base hits from second
base and by the way brings a british
pretty good glove to right field you see
the glove work the angles and he's got
an absolute cannon of an arm as bryce
hyper as bryce harper is going to find
out right he's like oh no i had a double
for sure
he's just a total package and it's one
of these guys
we get spoiled by seeing the trouts and
the harpers and you know the acuna
juniors that juan soto those guys at 21
22 20 and they're just taking the league
by storm i mean what what i like most
about this guy in 2019
41 home runs 37 stolen bases and 883 on
ops the following year i know 2020 was a
shortened season it's a hundred points
higher in ops so what does that tell me
it tells me he's walking more he
understands what he should be swinging
at and understands better what he should
not be swinging at and the slugging is
going up usually that comes
later in your career well at 23 you know
i picture myself at 23. i was in double
a you know this guy's taking the league
by storm so it's just you know it's a
talent that is well beyond his years and
it seems like the sky's the limit for
him i mean he can literally you know you
put freddie freeman in that same
category those two guys can put a team
on their back for seven to ten days at a
time and say hey jump on i'll win you
four or five games real real special
talent yeah the fact that freeman was
the mvp last year acuna could be the mvp
this year ozuna's finally picked up a
little bit after a slow start you've got
ozzy albies i mean that offense is going
to score i mean i think that's going to
be the key right now for them whole
question
when we're talking about the brayson and
ashley's quite simply who's going to win
today braves of the nationals again the
pitching match was drew smiley versus
john lester smiley unfortunately has
struggled out of the gate with that 19
innings at 805 era not the 31 with
atlanta you see john lester five innings
so far yet to give up a run so that is
the poll question who wins today atlanta
or washington
when we come back here on our pregame
show once again building up to the
braves and the nationals coming up at
the top of the hour a good match up here
in the nles and a couple of great guests
coming up on the other side don't go
anywhere
[Applause]
there it goes game winner
c
you
later
oh my goodness
112 miles an hour
463 feet carl schwartwer finally got one
[Music]
[Applause]
there's two home runs on the season and
both of them have been walk-offs and
that's why you don't bunt apparently
not with this guy one ball two strikes
two out nobody on top of the knife
scherzer's into the wind-up the kick and
the one-two pitch
w's in the box
and for
the
max
strikeout of the afternoon
it is a complete game victory the 12th
of his career and the nationals out of
the dugout to congratulate max scherzer
[Applause]
you're watching the mlb game of the week
pregame show presented by global citizen
vax live stream the extended show only
on youtube this saturday at 8pm eastern
when you look at the war leaders among
nl shortstop since the start of 2019
trey turner right in the mix second only
to trevor story ahead of javier baez and
fernando tatis jr who is so stellar for
san diego and that's where we begin as
we bring in trey turner of the
washington nationals trade every time i
watch you i see this guy's got to be the
most underrated star in the game do you
feel that way about yourself too
i i don't worry about that stuff you
know i'm i'm out here trying to you know
give my offer for the guys in clubhouse
and and uh you know the fans in the
stadium and um you know i just enjoy
playing the game i enjoy competing and
showing up every day and and trying to
get those wins and uh you know i have a
lot of fun doing it so
let you guys decide all that stuff but i
just enjoy playing trey mike lowell here
hey last year i know it was a shortened
season but it was a monster season for
you led the league in hits triples you
hit 335 and ops just shy of a thousand
you're off to a great start this year do
you feel like you're coming into your
own in every aspect of your game
yeah i think uh you know i always strive
to try to get better
defensively offensively and you know
base running so i'm always searching for
for you know tweaks and trying to become
more consistent and you know i think
last year i took a good step forward i
think it started in 2019 and then
took another step forward last year and
then hopefully you know i can make some
more more progress this year in all
facets and
you know i'm having fun with the
coaching staff and coming in every day
and trying to find those tweaks like i
said and um you know hopefully make some
more progress our colleague tom bernucci
did a great piece in your last year trey
and in it your mom was quite talking
about the importance of being a batting
champion i thought it was a great quote
to listen today who cares about the ops
champion a batting champion's pretty
cool tell me about mom and her love and
support of you going after batting
titles
yeah my mom my mom's a hard one on me my
dad's actually pretty easy my mom will
you know if i go three for four she'll
ask me why i struck out so um she you
know she's always on me that's how it's
been since day one and early on in my
baseball career um and she kind of has
instilled the competitiveness in me um
so you know anytime i can win something
i think she's happy whether it's you
know stone bases batting batting title
or most hits whatever it is she wants to
see me at the top she's you know a huge
fan obviously so um you know whatever
you know whatever it is that year last
year was you know the average and the
hits and whatnot so she wants to see me
win that stuff and she's got a or i got
her full support which is which is nice
trey seven home runs seven stolen bases
that's on pace for 40 40. are there
certain numbers you set out to to
accomplish to attain during the season
before it starts
no i i don't i don't like to do that
because i mean
you know what's a good year you got to
beat what you did last year or
you know i don't i don't know i don't
know what what good numbers are per se i
just try to not give anything away i
think you know a long season if you know
every every day you can go four or five
at bats and not give anything away i
think the numbers are going to be there
at the end of the year whatever they are
they are but for me it's just competing
and um you know last last night for
example wasn't so good in the first few
bats but i tried competing and you know
snuck a homer in there so um you know
that's kind of
what i want to do each and every day
just not give stuff away
and just try to compete trey one of the
coolest stories for the nationals so far
this year is your teammate max scherzer
not only pitches a complete game then
goes to the hospital and his wife gives
birth to one of his children now i know
he wasn't in labor but still pretty
impressive the guy pitches the complete
game and then is there for the birth
those two uh those two are amazing him
and his wife are amazing i mean she had
to go through the whole day and prep for
a for a child and he didn't show up
until you know what an hour or two
before the kid was born so um you know i
took my cap to her she
she probably had a rough day and you
know i'm happy that everybody's healthy
and the baby was born but he went out
there and of course through nine innings
when you know hopefully get sick shutout
innings and get out of the ballpark and
go have your kid but now he had to go
all nine and
you know we got the win so it was a good
day for the scherzer family
trey lindor signs a huge deal tatis does
as well there's four big time shortstops
that are going to be free agents correa
seeger story
even javi baez you're a free agent not
next year but the year after that is it
hard not to see the contracts and and
your numbers are right there with these
guys is it hard to tune that out and see
what's possibly on the horizon for you
no i mean i don't want to tune it out
because i want to see that the game's in
a healthy place you know i've said it
you know
time and time again if you know players
are getting a lot of money that means
fans are showing up people are watching
the game
the game's in a good place financially
so i want everybody to get as much money
as possible and those guys to be happy
but for me i always think that if you
know you
you focus on what's in front of you that
you know that stuff will take care of
itself so um you know you got to play
the game and and you gotta enjoy playing
the game and you know wherever those
dollars end up they end up but for me i
just focus on trying to trying to
compete and trying to win and um you
know have a good good season a lot of
dollars becoming your way and your
teammate juan soto who's just incredible
to watch what impresses us the most i
think is just his ability to be such a
good hitter he's such a young age trey
and so patient like he doesn't swing at
bad pitches what impresses you the most
about soto
yeah it's that uh it's you know it's the
plate discipline but it you know it's
the competitiveness it's the mind
it's the work ethic it's many things um
you know i think uh another thing that
stands out for me is the oppo power when
when you can drive the ball to all
fields um you know you're going to be
dangerous and he hits every pitch in
every zone so um you know it's going to
be a bright
bright career for him and a special
career for him he's got to keep going
and keep doing what he's doing and he's
he's on the right path and uh he's
special and he's really really good well
trey juan soto is on the mend we should
see him hopefully in a full dh role when
you guys take on the yankees you got
strauss hopefully coming back soon you
guys are 12 and 14. i'm sure no one's
really happy with that but
everyone's kind of beating up each other
into division you're just a game and a
half out are you guys a little bit lucky
that no one has kind of pulled away in
this nl east
yeah i would say a little bit i mean i
think i think we've could have pulled
away for the most part i know we've been
banged up but um we've had chances to
win a lot of ball games and um you know
i think it's it's all about perspective
i think we're in a good spot right now
in the last few years we started 19 and
31 so i mean i think we're off to a
little bit better start than that as of
right now so um it's about perspective
it's about competing every day and um
you know the guys in clubhouse we we're
uh we're in a good spot mentally and
physically or getting there physically i
guess i should say so
when we get those guys back it's going
to be you know time to make a push and
try to get out to you know to a lead
it's it's not easy though these you know
these teams are good everybody's
competing
i know we've um
i think i guess everybody's kind of
struggled but it's anybody's division
and you know why not us so uh hopefully
in these next few weeks we can start
playing a little bit better and and get
out to a lead i know you say don't set
goals yourself trey with a name like
trey turner i always hope that you lead
the league in triples okay it just makes
sense in my world and it's always fun to
see it with your talent it's always a
possibility thanks for the time today
have a continued great rest of the
season
thank you guys appreciate it
[Music]
time now for a crater spotlight and i
love these guys already benny no
a gigantic dodgers fan who loves playing
video games with his wild and crazy son
they vlog about their life around
baseball and that favorite mlb moment
finding out betty was going to be a dad
while attending opening day april fool's
what we're going to get in that story in
just a second let's bring in betty no
right now and his fantastic son lumpy
that's right i said lumpy when i looked
it up i said oh it must be lefty no no
it is lumpy so let's start there benny
how did your great wonderful son get the
name lumpy
well he literally got the name like 30
seconds after he was born so what
happened was his head was super bumpy
so the first name that came to my mind
was hey i'm going to call him lumpy and
just like that it's been his name ever
since we call him and lumpy what's your
reaction when you tell your friends hey
how you doing my name is lumpy how are
you
i don't usually do that they just call
me a regular benny but
i just don't want to know them but
sometimes they know it
well as long as they know something
about you that's good news i know
obviously you guys are gigantic dodgers
fans you love playing mlb the show now
you both can't play as the dodgers right
so which team do you guys play as dad
so we both like playing with our uh with
our created teams
with those teams you can play with old
players new players and actually create
your own players so he's team lumpsters
monsters on team jolly fries because i
love french fries so we usually play
with those two teams
it's a lot of fun like i said and um
yeah you get to play with any any player
you can you can find in the creative
player is what really makes it cool uh
like the creator player for him is an 18
year old version of himself he's got a
exaggeratingly long
beard the player for me has a huge
stomach you know the belt protrudes out
and it's just like you know like
stomachs
exactly
well listen anytime you're replicating
the real game as much as possible
putting yourself in the game i'm in
favor of that but make yourself a little
slimmer betty it's okay it's just a game
not a big deal
you guys obviously both love the dodgers
lumpy who's your favorite dodger
smokey bets oh yeah and what do you love
about mookie beds
uh when the world series happened he
made a cool diving catch and he did the
king
[Applause]
[Laughter]
benny how about for you favorite current
dodger
uh no doubt clayton kershaw to me is the
best pitcher i've had the pleasure to
watch in person
from his amazing opening day in 2013
there was no hitter that's when i was
born i actually got to meet him and have
him sign my uh no hitter ticket stub
which was awesome and then of course
watching him run on the field
to celebrate with his teammates and when
they won the 2020
i was born in 2013 he was born in 2015.
well that's a yeah we're gonna get to
that 2013 story in a second lumpy don't
worry but i agree with benny when the
dodgers actually won and that camera
showed him running out that was my
favorite moment also when dave roberts
was telling clayton as fox was going to
break he said i'm so happy for you i'm
so proud of you it was such a great
great moment if you love baseball lumpy
what was your favorite moment of the
dodgers playoff run last year aside from
the final out when aurenus gets the
final out what was your favorite moment
watching with your dad
um my favorite moment when the areas
went down and he was so excited and
actually my dad was there
and his friend was there yeah we were
there and uh my favorite moment was uh
when they pulled blake snell out of the
game
i can't lie
the whole air just sucked out of the
building it was amazing i was there and
uh i remember looking at my friend bobby
who was also there and we both were like
you know what we're going to win this
game yeah my friend t-mobile was there
too it was epic but yeah when they
pulled blake snow i was like we're going
to win
did you see your friend t-mobile
yeah we have a friend uh play softball
with me and my friend uh dodger films
and we call him t-mobile because that's
you know where he works oh okay
so make sure i heard that correctly and
yes blake's still getting pulled a
forgettable moment for the raise
unforgettable for the dodgers betty how
about your all-time favorite dodgers
moment and you can't say i know this
predates you but 81 because being
canadian i have a lot of expos fans blue
monday rick money the home run off steve
rogers so don't mention that favorite
all-time dodgers moment okay
uh well until recently it was the the
kurt gibson home run you know because i
got to see that as a as a kid on tv but
definitely being there in person to
watch them win in 2020
takes the cake for sure i mean i can't
imagine topping that unless they win it
this year at dodger stadium you know we
were there for the final out yeah this
is this was our reaction i mean you can
see it all on my face right here i mean
it was just joyous i mean so many
emotions
they've disappointed for so long and
then to see them pull through and win
was just
phenomenal and i can't imagine topping
that moment to be honest uh and it's
awesome because it's always about
fathers and sons lumpy do you appreciate
how cool this is you get to see a
dodgers world series champion and you
get to celebrate with your dad do you
appreciate how great that is
oh yeah
it's amazing as you see this follow out
once again
the worst part that i hated that he
didn't get me to go there he didn't have
a much ticket yeah unfortunately we
didn't have an extra ticket for the
lobster but uh you know don't be don't
be too uh too bad he's over on tv he was
at game one of the 2017 world series so
he's been to world series games before
just you know hasn't been there to see
them win it and listen lumpy
beggars can't be chooses here okay as
long as get to go to a world series game
don't worry you don't have to be at the
actual clincher last one for you because
you mentioned off the top bendy tell me
the story when you found out you were
going to have lumpy april fools at a
dodgers game what
yeah april 1st 2013 my dad and it was
our first opening day
we go clayton kershaw has a phenomenal
day
pitched a shutout hit a home run to
center field
um and then you know they won the game
so on top of that when we're walking
back to the car my wife calls me and
she's like uh
you're gonna be a dad and i'm like well
it's april fool's day so do i really is
it for reals and she's like no you're
gonna be a dad and it was just like it
already made an amazing day that much
more amazing and what was really cool
was a couple days later i did manage to
get a commemorative baseball that had
the opening day logo on it and that is a
baseball that i hold near and dear to my
heart and it's i still have it of course
and uh yeah it was just a phenomenal day
and the way everything played out i mean
april fools of course it was just you
know you don't forget something like
that you know
no question about it fathers and sons
and baseball there's nothing sweeter
than that and uh we appreciate you guys
loving the la dodgers i just love the
name lumpy makes you think of stump
merrell who got that name because you're
standing next to a couple of tall guys
the guy who's that who's the stumpy guy
but instead this is lumpy because it was
the way he came out of birth i love it
um great stuff guys all the best and say
hi to t-mobile next time we'll get mason
t-bar out there with you thanks for the
time
thanks guys
all right bye
great stuff there from benny no and
lumpy rolled the cooney jr has been
sensational so far with the atlanta
braves this needs the mvp of the
national league anytime he's on tv
that's must-see tv it's coming up on
youtube braves and nationals your mlb
game of the week
[Applause]
now let's see ronald gafflin so we can
see the big fella run no just hitting
the seats
high
[Applause]
glad you called it the seat i mean
[Applause]
high fly ball off speed he crushed that
baby marcelo zona has put the braves in
front yeah take a selfie marcel and the
grand tour well right on cue chip you
talked about the struggles with the
breaking ball you talk about the extra
work they've been putting in and it pays
off want to let that go as long as it
can but like we talked about
fly ball felt it he's back long home run
how far up the fleet chooses that goal
so his first hit since april 17
481 feet for acuna
that was worth being interrupted
that ball was hammered
[Music]
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
pregame show presented by global citizen
vax live streaming extended show only on
youtube this saturday at 8 00 pm eastern
alongside mike lowell and adam burke
it's time for picks to click presented
by fan dual sports we got some good ones
here for this game coming up the braves
and nationals first and foremost mike
total runs scored putting the number out
there at nine what do you think over or
under oh i'm going under i think you
know john lester's coming off a good
start i think he's gonna do all right
and drew smiley's gotta you know come
back to the average you know he's gotta
keep the ball in the park home runs have
really hurt him so i'm gonna go under
i'm thinking seven eight ish yeah smiley
definitely struggled so far this season
you got a john lester story for me all
your years in baseball well
one thing with johnny lester is when you
see him he's a much bigger human being
than you think it's big tree trunk legs
fearless you know it was such a great
story in 07 when you know he came over
his his cancer scare
and was able to be so
so important for us you know to have
that guy start game four of the world
series you know it was something truly
special also he threw a no-hitter so you
know just
little milestones and you know i think
the pinnacle was he signs a big deal
with the cubs and he he lives up to all
the all the big hype the expectations
they win the world series so you know
one of my favorite teammates just you
know a down earth humble guy and i think
he's he's he's a valuable asset to the
to the nationals especially with
strasbourg down a little bit hopefully
he comes back soon they're going to need
they're going to need johnny lester yeah
lester's numbers were not as great last
year but he pitches he's out there he'll
eat up innings and he'll definitely
battle and compete on that one-year deal
all right up here right now on an nle's
team philadelphia phillies are taking
the milwaukee bros alec baum
bad to the bomb here for the phillies
this offense mike they can score runs
not many today they pitch great though
two nothing how about wheeler complete
game eight k's nice philly i'll tell you
what the phillies have kind of been
turning on the juice lately and alec
bone that's a big sign he got off to a
little bit of a slow start monster
popping that back good to see him going
the other way great pitching is woodrow
from the brewers best stars 11
strikeouts and six and two thirds the
phillies do end up winning the game this
brings us to the topic of the favorite
for the nles as i said off the top you
could have made a case this might be the
best division in baseball instead it's a
lot of mediocrity right now who do you
think ends up separating themselves from
the package wow it's tough i tell you
any team right now i think they've all
under performed yeah and still the
marlins in last place are two games out
you know so anyone's in a good spot i do
still like the braves you know max free
looked good you know he came back
yesterday mike sorelka hopefully he's
coming back later in the year i think
the offense is you know they have
obviously what i think is the mvp so far
in the cuny junior freddie freeman it's
just a nice mix i i believe they're
actually going to really start to turn
it on and and be able to hopefully
separate themselves i did like the
atlanta braves at the start of the
season concerned about their pitching
they do have those horses mets by the
way right now the favorite corner of the
odds so if that offense picks it up
we'll see next question here for you
have an underdog pick for mvp you
mentioned cuny right now listen the
guy's the runaway favorite but is there
a player you think you know what under
the radar this guy's got a good chance
well i don't know if my pick is actually
under the radar but that's an mvp pick
he's under the radar because he's a
pitcher i'm going with jacob the grom i
mean i look at it it's
it's five starts at man point 5 era i
mean he's averaging 15 strikeouts per 9
and a walk and a walk and four hits i
mean he's averaging five guys getting on
base let alone giving up runs so if for
some reason he can keep this up for six
months i just think the numbers are
going to be so staggering that he's got
to get some mvp votes are you a fan of
that by the way when a pitcher gets an
mvp if it's if it's a year for i
favorite if it's a year where a position
player no one really stood out
and a pitcher just absolutely dominated
the league i'm i'm okay with it i i'm
not a huge fan if they're a good
position like if acuna junior hits 55
and you know i think guys like that
deserve it because there is an award for
pitchers exactly they got their award
but you're right if de graham is going
to be ridiculous he degrominates watch
out i'm glad he bets it plus 1300
because he's been great for the dodgers
and obviously la's gonna be in the mix
poll results by the way for our question
which was off the top real simple who's
gonna win today's game atlanta braves at
70 percent the nationals right now at 30
well according to the numbers it really
has been the braves who have had
washington's number they've won four or
five games against the nats this season
the team has five games under 500 versus
all their teams and all five games have
come in dc so that game is coming up
momentarily here uh some news and notes
to pass along albert pools could be the
end of an incredible career designated
for assignment by the angels carlos
carrasco moved to the 60-day il eligible
to turn may 31st and as mike and i
discussed off the top happy birthday to
willie mays say hey celebrating his 90th
birthday the oldest living hall of famer
uh a final fight here on albert pools
could be the last we see at the great
albert pool i tell you his first 10
years are are really mind-blowing you
know it's a 330 average i think he
averaged 41 home runs and 123 runs about
it in with an ops over a thousand he was
21 and i just i was like how's this guy
dominating the league you know so
kudos to him it's an incredible career
if it's the end it's a sure first ballot
hall of famer if it's not there's a team
that's picking up a pretty good veteran
i know hopefully it's not the last we've
seen him but you're right the greatest
right-handed hitter of his era in those
first 10 years these stories say
dimaggio's first seven years best ever
for hall of famer albert's first ten in
st louis is the reason why i used to
call him the machine for mike lowell i'm
adam burke thanks so much for checking
us out the braves and the nationals come
right now on youtube enjoy the game
everybody
[Applause]
are you
[Applause]
late afternoon hardball in dc it'll be a
monumental accomplishment to take this
division and the two clubs that have
owned the nl east over the past decade
go at it on a global stage today it's
the mlb game of the week live on youtube
presented by global citizen max live
the atlanta braves have one more to go
in this series with the washington
nationals at nationals park
let's go hello everyone to the global
audience watching and listening
worldwide on youtube we're thrilled to
be here scott brown along with i'll say
it the perfect person to call this game
mark derosa has played four yes the
watch the nationals and the atlanta
braves you know these two franchises
very well derailed and both classy
organizations obviously born and raised
with the atlanta braves and towards the
twilight of my career got a chance to
kind of catch lightning in a bottle with
the nationals in 2012 when a lot of
these young players to stephen
strasburg's of the world and the trey
turners were bursting on the scene okay
braves fans like him nats fans like him
you know who else we like two of the
most viewed players on youtube trey
turner and ronald acuna jr are also two
of the most dynamic players in major
league baseball let's start off with
trey turner he's been on fire lately and
he's a guy we know he can run but he can
slug too scotty b that's the big thing i
mean when you look at this guy trey
turner he's taken it next level juan
soto's been out and since 2019 i felt
like he was damaged goods in the
postseason for the gnats what has he
done in the pandemic season of 2020 he
went completely off and he has picked up
right where 2020 left off with the pop
you take a look right here last 15 games
356 batting average but he's going deep
and he's going deep with two strikes on
him just continues to get better and you
see here scotty b take it since the
start of the 2020 season yeah he's a
stud and his manager dave martinez also
says his defense keeps improving you
want defense you want slug you want a
little speed on the bases ronald acuna
junior is your guy to lead off man
extraordinaire for the braves i can
argue to take mike trout out of it this
is the most exciting player in the
entire sport probably a guy that you
might want to start your franchise wit
you look first four major league seasons
i don't know
averaging 43 bombs in 31 stakes per 162
games and talking to brian snicker who's
been in the braves organization for
north of 45 years he's had everyone from
andrew to chipper jones you name it jeff
franco brian mccann coming through there
the list goes on and on and he says
nobody is more talented
than ronald de cuny junior that's ever
put on the atlanta braves uniform you
look at the 2021 season breakdown
obviously got off to just an epic start
419 with seven bombs since he's come
back from that kind of intercostal
strain early he struggled much like more
of the same with the entire atlanta
braves lineup and we stole another
stolen bag from him yesterday that's a
great sign he leads off for atlanta when
we swing back with lineups in first
pitch from the capital of usa it's free
on youtube tell your friends
get used to that major league baseball
[Applause]
deep to
a
left
slam
bouncing ball fair ball it's a walk-off
hit in the air to deep right field at
the wall we're tied up at three
you want to talk about one of those let
the kids play moments
we just saw one
ball's got a chance
he lays out and makes the diving catch
[Applause]
long home run
he is hotter than the georgia asphalt
[Applause]
[Applause]
almost game time and your starting nine
for the visiting atlanta braves is
presented by global citizen backs live
and our first great comment in the chat
section daddy dimutv we've seen two
grand slams this series what about a
third
this one from acuna he's leading the way
he's also leading baseball tied for the
most homers with ten switch hitting
albies is best friend hitting second
azuna with a grand slam in yesterday's
game and let's start with ronald acuna
jr we are underway
on youtube on a global audience scott
braun and mark derosa with you atlanta
braves washington nationals finishing up
a three-game set and here's the guy that
can do it all
in on the hands that's exactly the kind
of pitch that john lester wants to queue
up all day long harrison makes the catch
for out number one
[Applause]
you know this guy
yeah i think i've met him a time or two
37 years old coming off his first start
of the season had a little bit of a
delay for a variety of issues but um
including the covet injured list
he looked good in start number one 70
pitches five innings for the nationals
and they said we can go as long as he
wants to go he's john lester he's done
this for a long time and he's very
durable as he misses upstairs to ozzy
albies
scotty b this is a guy i mean no one's
more prepared he knows he's getting to
the twilight of his career he knows he's
got to do things a little bit
differently to get ready for a season
i think 2020 was a wash for a lot of
these veteran ball players and an
opportunity pitching a rotation with max
scherzer and steven strasberg and corbin
i don't think he could pass up the
opportunity and potentially get back to
the
postseason all these swings and misses
on a pitch up but dave martinez said it
time and time again as we check out the
spray chart for all these last 100
batted balls loves going to the left
side there's a switch hitter too keep in
mind but
dave martinez said the key for john
keep the ball down
well it's up and all bees with a lazy
fly ball to center
and that's put away by robles
so for a little more on john lester your
pitching breakdown is presented by
global citizen vaxx live what do we have
yeah let's look at it those first two a
b's jam sandwiches for both albies and
acuna talk about move the plate that's
exactly what he wants you he wants to
drive that cutter in and get you
thinking that six inches off the inner
half to most right-handers is a strike
okay drive downhill we talked to dave
martinez in the pregame he talked about
in today's day and age of wanting to
drive the ball north and south john's
got to work down in the zone with his
change-up cutter four-seam combination
and then silent motivation i've known mr
lester a long time
the 11 million they handed to drew
smiley i think john would have liked an
opportunity to go to atlanta the 6
million they handed to jake garrieta
back in chicago i think john would have
liked the opportunity to
chance at that so he's pitching for the
gnats i know he's health uh happy and
healthy but there's some silent
motivation here a little chip on the
shoulder the better in southpaw who gets
through the top three in the order for
atlanta bottom of the first we'll
introduce you to the nats lineup coming
up
ronald acuna in who singled
firmly to left field back in the first
this one struck well to center field
robles back
and a nice lunging catch
dives onto the warning track corrals it
what a play that ball is absolutely
roasted another hard hit ball for ron
laguna junior standing over from the
crowd here at nass park who else it's
ronald acuna jr
and a fly ball hit toward that
scoreboard in right center did he get
enough of it yes he did ronald lacuna jr
breaks a scoreless tie with a two out
solo homer
he's in double digits 10th homer of the
year in the braves strike first it's one
to nothing so atlanta has him loaded
with two outs lost scary noah's coming
up
and a high fly ball center that ball is
gonna go it's a grand slam for noah
that was a no doubter he knew it too
look at the smile on you noah's face
this feels good to see him in the
batter's box doesn't it
i don't care what the score is
just the last eight games with that left
shoulder strain
well welcome back juan soto
[Applause]
foreign
nationals half of the first coming up on
youtube easy to find us youtube.com mlb
it's free for everyone watching
worldwide join the nearly three million
other fans in subscribing to the mlb
youtube channel you can click that bell
icon to receive notifications prior to
upcoming games if you're a youtube tv
customer you get even more hooked up i'm
on board and now your national starting
lineup which is presented by global
citizen backslide trey turner the
shortstop crushing lefty so far this
season yadiel hernandez still in there
for juan soto who is available off the
bench josh harrison starlin castro and
josh bell at the top of the order for
the nationals and a strike delivered by
drew smiley on the mound making its
fifth start of the season gave up three
home runs five runs in five innings
against the toronto blue jays in a
little ballpark in dunedin florida last
time out
scotty i want you to take a look at trey
turner he doesn't does some things that
i've seen veteran ball players do with
zero and one strikes you'll see him give
you this modified leg kick right here
and then with two strikes you see o2 he
sets his front foot down takes all the
movement out of his swing and just kind
of plays pepper the only difference with
the trey turner this year he's playing
pepper and going deep
he's had that pop it's been unleashed
even more so this year you're right
seven home runs already this season
414 average in his last seven games last
10 days
4 14.
best in the national league during that
time period and number two is on the
other side austin riley playing first
base today freddie freeman getting the
day off although available off the bench
as well we could have freeman and or
soto off the bench later stay tuned
and turner swings through good start for
smiley
it's tough as a manager you give both of
those guys your superstars those days
off and you see right here just a nice
feel for a breaking ball he's been
throwing that pitch a ton this year in
the early going drew smiley
at no point unless he's got a chance to
truly win the baseball game does brian
snicker want to look down to freddie and
tell him to get it going he wants to
give him the full mental day off to
relax
smiley's been hit hard so far this
season era north of five
misses on the first pitch to hernandez
yeah but you know he'll be tempted if
it's close
yesterday was really close
late in the game
yes and i know dave martinez thought
about juan soto in place of victor
robles in a huge spot in the eighth
inning but couldn't pull the trigger
soto pinch hit in the next inning yeah
you can't and i totally understood that
move you're not you're not pinch hit for
a starter of victor robles ilk in that
situation that could be that could do
more damage to victor mentally
than get the boys going if juan comes up
with a big knob
they also didn't have any outfielders
available after that it would have been
josh bell in the outfield for the
national sure which i'm sure he could do
yeah all right let's take a look and
break down mr drew smiley i've had a
chance to be in a box against this
left-hander as well even though it was
eight years ago late life you're gonna
see him blow forcing fastballs by some
guys and you're gonna wonder why his
ball presents itself at about 92 to 93
coming out of his hand but it has got
some nice run through the zone elevate
as we talked about mr lester working
down in his own you're gonna see a high
heater and then you're gonna see him
tunnel the breaking ball off of that and
swing mode the reason i write that is
when you're facing drew smiley if he's
around a dish everything kind of morphs
into one pitch and he gets you thinking
that everything's a strike and you start
pulling the trigger and you get
situations right there where yadiel
hernandez doesn't know if he should pull
the trigger or take it next thing you
know he's walking back to the dugout two
quick strikeouts for smiley that
scouting report presented by global
citizen backslide and
drew was a revelation last year i mean
strikeout stuff in limited work as that
one's filed off by josh harrison that's
why they signed him for big bucks yeah
the metrics were in love with mr smiley
last year again
all i can take you through is is is my
personal experience in the box with this
guy
i loved facing left-handed pitching that
was kind of what i made my hay on and i
get in a box against mr smiley and i'm
like whew that heater's moving a little
quicker than i gave it credit for
adrianza has to eat that one
slipped up a little bit over at the hot
corner
and josh harrison is aboard a two-out
base runner for the nationals
[Applause]
hey when it's going your way josh
harrison's gotten off to a hot start you
start getting those infield knocks
took a little hop on mr adrianza right
there is not able to put his hand in the
glove and make complete the play
harrison has reached base safely in 17
of 20 games this season andreyanza can
play all over the field
today at third so that riley can play
first in place of
freddie free
cleanup hitter today starlin castro look
at him doing damage against left-handed
pitching this season a few of the gnats
with
a big start against southpaws ryan
zimmerman of course off the bench can
hit lefties well
not shocked by that scotty you see a lot
of these veteran hitters the starling
castros the ryan zimmermans of the world
to josh harrison these are guys are
going to wear out that right center gap
against against left-handed pitch and
give them give them a chance line the
line to be successful
yesterday this lineup had trouble
against left-handed pitcher max freed
for atlanta that one just missed for
smiley a ball and a strike a lot of
keepers
if he's got that curveball working a lot
of people are going to have trouble
against him
braves fans were hyped to see the max
free that looked more like the 2020
version who was fantastic
[Applause]
this is the guy they want to get going
smiley's 1-1
and it's two-in-one
he struck out 42 batters last year in 26
in the third innings with san francisco
the giants
know how to find some starting pitches
they're doing it again this year too
alex wood
mr diesel funny out there
here's last year versus this year look
nine home runs allowed highest home run
rate
in baseball
you see that heater right there 93 it
just plays hotter than that starlin now
you're going to see him with two strikes
shorten his swing down he will not he
will not punch out on a similar fastball
in that situation
two strikeouts and then an infield
single for harrison here it comes see if
i'm
right or not
he's on it yep
hey josh harrison's on first he's also
mic'd up today which is awesome
mic check one two one two
come on you wanna say something to the
people
they watching on youtube
hey that's with my boy bogey two hands i
dropped a couple pop-ups bogey got me
right
that's awesome
i've heard tim bogar's name a lot
already yeah today working with trey
turner defensively obviously helping
josh harrison
just like ron washington on the atlanta
side
and there's a bag
for starlin castro
or make that harrison i'm sorry castro
at the plate look at harrison taking the
bag i wonder what he's saying hey if he
says anything good we'll have it for you
throughout the day austin reilly also
miked up for us on youtube today
i mean he's always talking harrison he's
fun he can dance
entertaining ball player that's ball
four to castro
[Applause]
don't scratch that no mic for riley it's
all josh harrison putting on the show
today
he'll provide plenty of commentary for
us and hey i know you saw last week we
had shane bieber and nelson cruz yes and
you played it the other day on on your
show on mlb network shane bieber talking
about charcuterie yes
one of his teammates i think pronounced
it charshutter
chartreuse
yeah get out of here
switch hitting josh bell one of the two
big power bats that the gnats picked up
in the off season
off to a slow start although dave
martinez told us before the games we're
starting to see some baseballs in the
air for both belle and schwarber so
they're feeling like it's coming
he has to hit bottom line if the
nationals are going to be successful the
kyle schwarbers the josh bells patrick
corbins
gotta refined what the back of their
baseball card has always been
this one's on the ground
and albie's has plenty of time to put
him away
so two left on for the nationals nothing
to show for it scoreless after one in dc
so now they walk freddie freeman and go
righty righty with ozuna base is loaded
two down and he swings the first one and
launches it to right field harrison back
turns it is gone a grand slam frozuna on
the first pitch brings up william
contreras who sparked the big rally in
the third inning as contreras 3-0 count
got the green light he lifts one to
center field to the deepest part of the
ballpark first career home run for
william contreras here's the pitch to
golf
don golves left field and john gomes has
his second home run of the home stands
this guy's heating up 29 year old
right-hander making his 13th appearance
strike three called and there it is an
immaculate inning an immaculate inning
for kyle finnegan nine pitches three k's
three straight three pitch strikeouts
kyle finnegan strikes out the side on
nine pitches and that folks is an
immaculate inning so here's trey turner
with one aboard do some damage in the
eighth inning
swing along drive to left field
[Applause]
it's a two run homer for trey turner the
bases are full for victor robles
and the pitch is hit high in the air to
left on the first pitch braves get out
of it the gnats get two but they don't
get the lead
i'm excited to join you all live from
nationals park and you know this game
has all the makings to be so exciting
you have juan soto available off the
bench and you have ronaldo community
junior two young guys in this league
that are really exciting and fun to
watch so i'm going to ask you guys back
in the studio and everyone watching on
youtube if you were building a franchise
or a team right now who would you build
one around we have a few options for you
we have juan soto ronaldo pugna junior
fernando tatis jr and vlad guerrero jr
guys who are you building your team
around wow savannah really putting the
pressure on in the second inning dyro's
sweating now
you can't go wrong
can you i mean you really somebody's
we're gonna
that guy was the choice
don't you think uh yes and no i think he
got three potential guys destined for
cooper's town if health and uh
listen juan soto's ted williams right so
what do you want you want
the guaranteed offensive player do you
want a little bit more swag and flash
ronald de cunha and more tools
i lean towards what i was born and
raised to do and that was you know play
a premium defensive position up the
middle
control the game on both sides of the
ball fernando tatis jr for me
playing shortstop even though he
struggled defensively
kind of what he brings the entire skill
set
would be where i would lean
hernandez but i'll gladly catch him
right i'll gladly take juan soto yeah
soto
would be out there and right hernandez
replacing him today soda's gonna
hopefully pinch it for the team later on
in this game and then he'll dh this
weekend in the bronx against the yankees
and then by next week maybe we see him
back in the field coming off a shoulder
issue and kind of rehabbing while he's
up on the big league team he's okay to
hit but not ready to play in right field
just yet
so riley flies out now it's swanson
poll results later by the way of course
we'll pay that off for you see who wins
braves and nats fans of course probably
dominating the section right now and
also maybe disagreeing with d-ro on his
selection i'm sure they are tatis that's
all right
i'll gladly pick third too
yeah if that man everyone falls to me
i'll gladly take him
a few
from our youtube creators
in the live chat right now antonelli
baseball said acuna for me but i'll take
any of them
i mean see there's a classic case 87
right there that's a good take by dansby
swanson in a hitter's count john tried
to present that middle in heater and
would have got a jam sandwich
had dans be swung at that pitch
dansby's fighting a battle right now do
i sit fastball in or am i looking change
up out over
hitters count he's got one homer against
leicester in his career there's a strike
working the other end of the plate
[Applause]
that's what we discussed talk about
moving the plate he threw the 3-0 pitch
in off and got the call so dan's we
thought the plate had moved a little bit
in
just taking that pitch right out of the
hand probably was a ball outside but
mr lester's been doing it a long time
that little backdoor cutter
that one missed
extra few inches off the plate
and swanson receives the base a pitch
later
and dansby over eight in his first two
games in this series two for his last 18
but he's on board with one down in the
top of the second
that brings us to adrianza
one for his last 11 and another story
connected to him why he's playing today
riley the first
freddie freeman receiving
a day off mental break he could appear
later as a pinch hitter but the first
day off of the season for the reigning
nlmvp the swing just looks a little off
for him
you know it's funny freddy's not a guy i
sit here and i try and break down all
these swings i mean i didn't learn how
to
be comfortable in the box till i was
almost 30 years old so that's why i
grind so hard on it trying to study it
ask all the veterans and all the current
players and the younger guys what they
do at the plate freddie is not a guy
that's really fundamentally based
he's an octopus at the plate i mean
the reason i say that i feel like he can
cover everything
and he's just trying to hit shortstop
over over uh line drive over the
shortstop's head and feels like when you
talk to him he doesn't hunt fastball he
kind of hunts strike zone and feels he
can cover it all
i don't know that feeling is what i'm
saying
not many do
i like the octopus reference righty
lefty and he does not matter any pitch
runners on
especially with runners in scoring
position he's been one of the best for
the past decade relievers starters
scotty the numbers it's all there he
won't move if you lock in on a braves
game start to finish you'll notice
something freddy is never not in the
dugout he's not in the video room he's
not a guy that goes watches is that bats
he sits in the exact same spot in the
dugout for 162.
it's pretty impressive not many guys do
that he's there chipper jones
leader of the clubhouse
and the last mvp before freddie was
chipper in 1999
that's right
where were you in 99 i got called up i
was a part of that i got called up in
june to the braves yeah chipper showed
up to spring training and you knew
it was it was on
he was feeling it he was feeling march
he destroyed the mets consistently i
think the yankees came in
had a series of inner league series that
he went bonkers in
[Applause]
you take a look at this 2020 mlb ranks i
mean
he's been the best hitter in the
national league
defender
legacy type player i know alex antopolis
is watching this i got to believe
they're sharpening the pencil at some
point and signing him to an extension
free agent after the year if it doesn't
happen
and i'll say this you got a lot of young
superstars on the rise i know the albies
and the acunas have already signed but
the young players watch the way these
veterans are treated come contract time
and i think
it would behoove the atlanta braves to
do the right thing with freddie runner
on the move and swanson is out strike
him out throw him out swanson wants them
to check it
adrianza down on strikes john gomes has
a cannon mine what do you got i got out
i got out okay
i mean are you ever gonna say no i'm
good don't check it
have you ever read the guy i've never
had this steel sign scotty i don't know
here it is again
harrison lays on the tag
[Applause]
big turnaround
for john lester and the washington
nationals strike him out throw him out
forget the replay it happened
[Music]
here it is
swung on lifted high and deep to right
field headed for the chop house heads up
out there gone home run freddie freeman
he said my elbow feels fine it feels
like i got hit with a baseball but i'm
good to go and he showed you that with
the first inning single
golfed into right center field marisnak
won't get there that's down for a base
hit you know around thirds gonna get the
green light the cubs miss the cutoff man
and aconia is coming
one out to left field home that'll drop
in for a base hit cutting it off as
chris bryant third base of the night for
freddy freeman
hanger and a high fly ball deep right
field it's a perfect night for freeman
seven homers for freddie
nine-nothing atlanta
every right back where it came from off
the pitcher's back hip
and guerrero can't make the play
adriana's gonna come home and score and
everybody's safe for atlanta to make it
12-3 yeah
18 rbis for freeman
that came back a whole lot faster than
it headed to the plate
[Music]
no score yet in d.c and another unique
aspect of watching games on youtube we
just unveiled our first interactive poll
of the day it allows you to offer a
multiple choice response to questions
posed in the live game commentary stay
tuned results will be revealed and
discussed later in the broadcast we
started with who are you starting your
team with we'll get to some results a
little bit later on also in the live
chat section our youtube creators i'm
looking for questions from you right now
max yours or later but first ian
anderson about to join us on youtube as
drew smiley gets ready for the bottom of
the second inning against john gomes who
just showed off his arm in the previous
half and here we go ian anderson joining
us in the dugout ian and scott brown and
mark derosa good afternoon how you doing
today
good guys how's it going really good and
we'll get some questions in here from
the youtube creators but i'll start us
off because i'd like to know how much
pressure is on the pitching staff with
the way that wascar yanoa is showing up
at the plate right now slugging 923 with
a homer in a grand slam in the past week
of baseball how's he looking
yeah
that's impressive um
you know what he's been able to do so
far i think it's it's overshadowing what
he's been able to do on the mound and i
think that's
you know that's pretty crazy because
he's been pretty damn good on the mound
for us so
yeah we gotta we got a lot of pressure
with what he's been doing
we're showing it april 28th this one off
kyle hendricks handles a hanger
looks like a pro oh my goodness the
responses were incredible
from the dugout and then tuesday in this
series off tanner rainey the grand slam
to center field
watching it too
looks like he belongs forget the
designated hitter that one skyed by
schwarber that should be playable for
marcelazuna so two quick fly ball outs
here in the bottom of the second he
looks like he's a dh these days ian
yeah no he hits the ball hard i mean
he's got six hits i think they're all
over 100 so
they're no cheapies
and i want to ask you man you were a
savior last year for this rotation not
only a regular season but in the
postseason then this year you show up
sorok is still down freed goes down
i feel like you haven't had a chance to
like be a rookie you've had to like
carry the burden of this rotation how
have you been able to kind of put that
on your shoulders and and still be
productive
yeah no it's uh obviously
not having sorok has been tough but i
think the whole organization's kind of
just been that you know next man up
mentality you know huascar coming in
doing what he's been able to do
and that's kind of the mindset i kind of
took on you know don't don't miss this
chance to to go out and kind of
show show that i belong and show that i
can stay here and
the team's had some success so it's been
it's been fun
it must not feel like you're still a
rookie i mean i covered you in october
last year you flogged some time
yeah no that definitely helped i mean
that was such a such a good experience
for everyone um you know we we have such
a young team and
um you know for us to go through that
obviously it didn't end how we we quite
wanted it to but
um i mean we've taken numerous things
into this year and you know the results
might not not be there yet but
um you know we're staying the course and
and uh we're excited still about the
team we have and uh you know the way
we've been playing the last few has kind
of showed that i'll mix in one here from
the live chat because this innings
moving drew smiley filling up the zone
now and could be one pitch away movie
gaming tv who is the funniest player in
the clubhouse
uh that's gotta be luke jackson wow one
of our relievers um
he's he's hilarious man he's you know
he'll have your belly laughing at least
once a game and
um he ended up taking the guys on on a
bike tour through uh dc monuments on the
off day so
[Laughter]
he's
he's he's a he's a bit of a he's a bit
of a character so i i think everyone
would probably agree so it's probably
unanimous
that one is shot to deep left off the
bat of victor robles heading back to the
track of zuzuna that's right he's there
you have a better view than we do ian
and you were awesome appreciate the time
man keep it up all right we'll talk soon
yup thank you guys that's ian anderson
of the atlanta braves so one two three
frame for drew smiley no score after two
[Music]
and a breaking ball hit in the air left
field deep this is way back this may go
and it is gone goodbye
bang zoom goes
turner swing a high drive left center
field does he have another one going
back guerrielle to the track to the wall
and that one is long gone
it's trey turner two and the blue jays
nothing
and trey's on it laces that one into
left field for a lead off single here in
the first
as trey smokes one through the hole nice
swing have a series trey turner faces
loaded
putter this time slow grounder trey's
gonna barehand it and what a play wow
huge play by trey turner robles will
take off turner puts it in play to
center field
and this one will drop
there's the two one to trey
out to right field we'll back up biggio
and it's over his head
that ball just kept traveling and trey
turner has himself a four for four day
his line sharply in one hop a diving
stop turner on the outfield grass gets
up throws and gets him by a step another
special play for trey turner takes it
away from jesus aguilar
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by global citizen vax
live stream the extended show only on
youtube this saturday eight o'clock
eastern and it's a stacked lineup hosted
by selena gomez tons of performances
from huge names eddie better is going to
perform i'll give you a few other ones
later because we have our poll results
if you were starting a team today who
would you build around looks like braves
fans are watching on youtube today and
hey you can't go wrong with any of these
options but ronald acuna jr taking 57 of
the pie as john lester gets ready to
face seven eight and nine first pitch
swinging gobbled up at third by castro
and his throw is on the mark in time
absolutely awesome play like by starland
castro right there you know got mr pache
he's got super wheels getting down to
first he's playing even with the bag
with the bunt
a little backhand to the feet get rid of
it
[Applause]
i throw josh bell handles
and there's out number one man no
hesitation right here
and the one thing that's nice too you
got mr josh bell over at first base you
don't even have to turn and look to
throw
he's got that catch radius you're pretty
much getting him get it in the vicinity
castro was a short stop for the cubs
and playing some second base for the
nationals which is where he said he
prefers at this point but handling the
hot corner nicely
so after pache is jeff mathis
[Applause]
38 year old veteran
i thought it was interesting today
talking to brian snicker in the zoom
conference
why mathis was in there
he wanted him to take a crack at getting
drew smiley going he's such a veteran
presence let maybe he's going to put the
right fingers down somebody's got to
unlock drew smiley
for the atlanta braves this can't be a
situation where you know you have one
year 11 he struggles we we gave one year
18 nicole hamill's last year we
never saw him so
we got to figure out a way to to piece
it together
brian snicker
in his 45th season with the atlanta
braves organization
joined the team as a non-drafted free
agent in 1977
2018 manager of the year
that sounds like
a good idea to give jeb mathis to drew
smiley mathis with a pristine reputation
handling pitchers
that one lofted off the bat of mathis a
little bermuda triangle action who has
it it's hernandez her
all right
pick your poison ronald acuna jr the
2018 nl rookie of the year is 23.
juan soto a little younger he's 22. he's
a batting champ and a world series champ
in 2019 fernando tatis jr all their age
these days in the nl west
the nl silva silver slugger last year
and look who has burst on the scene in
2021 vlady jr
the thing about acuna is
the ability to do everything and then
also do it at a level of like giancarlo
stanton exit velocity or distance but he
he's taking the numbers and making them
eye-popping he's hitting the ball north
of 480 feet he's got a north of a 95
mile an hour exit velocity on that i
mean the guy
there's nothing he can't do on a
baseball field and it's hard
to have a gorgeous right-handed baseball
swing
you know you think of the great gorgeous
swings you think of the left lefty guys
pulling the trigger
he is unhinged
in the way he goes about it from the
plate
drew smiley would love his swing no
career hits in 27 abs another thing
mr juan soto in 2019 the world series
showed everybody
why you can argue he's the best hitter
in the sport i mean what he was able to
do in that world series
i like to play that game
you talk about players an all-around
game but what about one at-bat to win me
again
yeah that's a complete i want juan soto
out of that group
and then if you throw it
the financials
the cuny side the most cost
effective deal that's a whole other
story 2400th career strikeout for john
lester congrats he's faced the minimum
through three
[Music]
high fly ball off speed he crushed that
baby marcelo zuna has put the braves in
front yeah take a selfie marcel and the
grand tour
high fly ball did he did he one score
his first home run
golfed into right center field maurizio
[Applause]
you know around thirds gonna get the
green light the cubs miss the cut off
man and aconia is coming home
and he slid in ahead of the tag and the
braves have scored six in the first two
innings
[Applause]
swing and a drive belted deep left
welcome back christian pache a grand
slam
had a kid
got the change up and absolutely
crushed it
fly ball felt it he's back
long home run how far up the plate does
that go
481 feet for acuna that was every bit of
it
[Applause]
heading into today the braves lead the
league with 44 home runs and i for one
love it when guys they flip their back
they strut around the bases but some
teams are getting a little bit more into
it than other ones our next poll
question comes and it's what's the best
home run celebration of the last five
years we have the twins there we have
the nationals in their 2019 pro season
driving the bus guys which one is your
favorite oh
i have recency bias so i'll go with the
uniqueness of the shopping cart started
by jason varatek and company where are
you going
dyro the selfie from marcelo zuna i mean
he kind of just changed the whole
dynamic last year with the braves and
just all the young
latin american born ball players just
they gravitated to him he changed to
cuny and albies and every now they got
the panda on the team i just i want to
be in a selfie with those guys
remember last year
in the wild card round against the
cincinnati reds
graves having some fun and then they
move on
eventually to face the dodgers after
getting through the marlins and they
were up three games to one one win away
from the world series but azuna brought
the thump he replaced josh donaldson in
the batting order perfectly
[Music]
we've been to dinner a hundred times and
i've told john lester since he's broke
into the game he needs to honor his
hitting a little bit more he has got pop
and he has got a gorgeous swing and
i mean he started his career like oh for
60 something
he can punt them
look at that hack there you go
good day for leicester on the mound so
far
three scoreless he's faced the minimum
nine
nine one and two due up for the
nationals here in the home third
scott braun mark derosa
we just heard from savannah mccann
he started his career oh for 66 matt
baker to the researcher to the stars in
my ear right here
oh for 66 with that swing so he had to
do some climbing to get over the 100
mark that he's at now
hey for everything we say about azuna
he's the only one on this list
defensively with a gold glove
believe that was in 2017 silver slugger
and gold glove winner back then he's had
some shoulder troubles since then
oh lester
couldn't bite
and smiley paints that's strike three
his third of the day drew smiley the
southpaw with the swing and missed up
today
and the nice command
new to the mlb game of the week for the
2021 season the youtube player of the
game fans watching on mobile devices and
computers can vote for which player will
receive the trophy and it's a nice one
during the post game show stay tuned for
the player of the game polling options
later in the show and d-ro will help you
out you can take his advice or leave it
major smiley making a strong case so far
this is what braves fans were hoping for
in the off season when they spent 11
million dollars on a one-year contract
for smiley coming off a big year with
the giants
of course last year
it was under 30 innings it was an
abbreviated season but when he was on
the mound
the braves thought they saw something
that could blossom even even further
yeah
obviously it took everyone by surprise i
think when he signed and he signed early
it was one year 11 million it wasn't one
year six one year seven where people
were like oh okay
this is a nice depth move no this is one
year eleven it's kind of like what the
yankees did with corey kluber asking
kluber to slot into their two slot
behind garrett cole that's a nice stop
at third you got to be quick on turner
and adrianza makes a brilliant play at
third base
[Music]
see him leaning towards the line a
little bit right there adrian adrianza
born and raised with the san francisco
giants played with this guy back in the
day he was just a young blood playing
shortstop it was all glove no bat and
what has been a steadiest send through
the minor leagues he started to swing
the swing to stick too
spring training was so good for him that
brian snicker said they had to put him
on the roster even though he wasn't
necessarily in the plans for 2021 that's
filed off by hernandez and think about
what's going through your mind at third
base after you make a play like that
trey turner is the fastest player in the
sport according to sprint speed from
statcast so you got to be quick with it
that's the beauty of playing third base
special especially for somebody
as good with the glove as mr adrianza
that's that's a day off for him at third
base
i like that
nice guy to have to fill in at third
base today and trey is over two
hernandez struck out against smiley
first time around
it's a great story too
hernandez
was a star in cuba
took a long time for him to find the
major leagues debuted last year
he's hit well so far in limited time
debuted last season at age 32
10 for 25 in his last eight filling in
for soto six seasons in cuba
three in washington's minor league
system
and dave martinez told us before the
game he's fun they love having him
around
lively guy in the clubhouse
soda's gonna come back hernandez is
gonna be
a bench player again but you think about
2019 and gerardo parra if you want some
personality and some fun off baby
yeah maybe hernandez makes that his
walk-up song
on the ground to the left side tough
play for swanson it's off the glove and
an infield knock for yadiel hernandez
here comes our man with the mic today
josh harrison
hey sometimes better be lucky than good
i saw him going backhand then i looked
and i saw him like this
that was dirty huh
that's a guy who has been in the league
for a while
knows
a lot of players around the game and is
comfortable with who he is
you know i watch you every morning d-ro
and one thing i do remember as josh
harrison goes after the first pitch i'll
have to be quick here fly ball but
you said you wish you had even more fun
oh you're playing josh harrison's doing
that
hey another good inning from drew smiley
he leaves one stranded still no score
three in the books in dc
swinging a ground ball left side diving
stop castro pops up throws to second
gets the out to retire the side a
sparkling defensive play for castro and
lester's out of trouble in the third
inning
pitch his line sharply in one hop a
diving stop turner on the outfield grass
gets up throws and gets him by a step
takes it away from jesus aguilar
and a breaking ball hit in the air to
left field deep this is way back this
may go and it is gone goodbye
bang zoom goes turner does he have
another one going back guerrielle to the
track to the wall and that one is long
gone
it's trey turner two and the blue jays
nothing
swinging a miss
mac scherzer
puts the finishing touches with a 96
mile an hour fastball for his ninth
strikeout of the ball game
swinging a long drive right center field
back on this one is harrison looking up
and this one is gone
into the second deck
it's a lead off walk off to run homer
for kyle schwarber and he sends him home
happy
[Applause]
[Music]
each week this season on our broadcast
we will focus on a youtube content
creator featured in our live game
commentary section today our creator
spotlight shines on benny no
on penny's channel you can watch this
dodger fan play video games with his son
and vlog about their lives around
baseball big following over 220 000
subscribers over 55 million views on his
videos
they love the dodgers
cute kid i believe he has two kids now
checked out a few videos it's benny no
some trouble
from the children in the house you've
been there d-ro
watch out for that fuzz that
that trophy i'm past it i'm in the good
years now
yeah what are the ages 17 and 11. there
you go
big cut and a miss from acuna to start
off the fourth inning for atlanta
i think the braves are going to have to
rethink that their colors
ronald is making a dead push to get gold
as a part of the atlanta braves colors
kind of honoring his venezuelan heritage
but a little iron man in there
i'm all in
look at
it
it shines
he has really taken atlanta by storm the
way soto has taken
washington dc i mean you just
haven't seen a player come as athletic
like this since andrew jones
raphael for call kind of like that
different type of vibe coming through
the screen
nl player of the month for april
he's cool
he runs he slugs
he sends one to left and we'll get to
watch him run the bases
ronaldo cuny junior starts off the
fourth with a base hit
now you see right here just to cut her
in
back in the day when john lester was
living at 92 93 miles an hour he could
bury that pitch in but you're going to
pitch it 88-89
against ronald cooney he's actually
lucky he gets that ball back and you see
right there his 2021 nl ranks i mean
he's the man get in line 111 miles an
hour off the bat for that single
he had three stolen bases in his first
10 games then none in his next 18 and
the braves are saying hey you can go you
have free reign just watch it on some of
the dives because we saw him dive back
to the bag
and suffer a mild abdominal strain
on the 18th of april
one more swipe this series so four on
the season
this is always a fun battle because john
lester does not love throwing over to
first base if you followed him in his
career
it's about the pausing right changing up
your timing coming to home plate
otherwise i'd love to see him throw over
at first it just doesn't happen
[Music]
i do believe ronald could go first move
right here and there's nothing john
could do to defend it so why isn't he
got already we're two pitches in
there we go there he goes
that's why dolby is the throw skips away
into center
and acunia is off to third
and just like that one of the flashiest
players in the game is 90 feet away from
scoring the game's first run yeah i just
don't think you hesitate against a guy
who's like you said scotty b chronicled
he does not like to throw over to first
base you got a guy like ron de cunha
who's got wheels for days he can go
first move even if he does throw that to
josh bell i still think he beats the
transfer to second
he's playing youth ball let me take it
on the third base once he sees josh
harrison miss this
brian snicker told us this morning
the ball field is his playground yeah
that's a great line
since 2019 one of the fastest
i would say
also wisely aggressive at the plate as
he continues to improve contact rate
and
decreases chase percentage
that's scary oh he's only gonna get
better when he knows how these guys are
gonna attack him i mean playing with
chipper jones all those years his his
attention to detail
before the game coming up with a game
plan knowing how guys are gonna attack
of what they're going to throw at
runners in scoring position
he's only going to get better
more walks than strikeouts this season
alby is his best friend facing a 2-2
and i love davey martinez defensive
position right here just not conceding
that early one run he knows lester and
smiley are both on top of their game
eventually we'll give it over to the
bullpen but he's got the infield kind of
playing halfway right here something hot
shot they're just not going to let a
cuny walk home
full boat
he missed
[Applause]
first two hitters of the frame on board
for atlanta runners on the corners that
brings us to ozuna
mr grand slam from yesterday i just want
to sneak this into next half inning
we're talking to max scherzer for a half
frame and oh any questions from our
youtube creators bring them on i got a
few i've written down yeah oh yeah oh he
had a day what about a week ago complete
game he's had a lot of days and then
goes over to watch his wife give birth
to their third kid azuna into the corner
and that's going to score the first run
of the day ronald acuna jr will trot
home and marcelazuna knocks in a run for
atlanta it's 1-0
see right here cutter inside from john
lester it's actually a great pitch
great pitch marcelo zuna almost knows he
wants to go to that well to get him to
roll over to third for a double play
kind of cheats to the spot
keeps it fair
one nothing bravo's first and now it's
second and third they are set up for a
big inning right here
the double for azuna is his third of the
season albee's at third
and here's a guy who's been swinging the
bat well lately
austin riley
has advanced himself
in terms of his plate discipline this
year alex antopolis gm of the squad said
much more selective than what we've seen
in the prior years and they're excited
about his own recognition so much so
that he said the ceiling for him might
be higher than they anticipated
yeah i think coming up through the brave
system the name i heard time and time
again was austin riley is troy gloss
and i kept saying troy had a
damn good career i mean light tower
power
picking granite third base played
shortstop coming up through uh ucla so i
mean that's a big comp
i think the thing that's jumped off for
me watching him on a nightly basis is we
never got a chance because he burst on
the scene as the left
fielder i didn't realize he could play
third as as admirably as he has today
he's at first then today he's at first
well we got to get freddie off his feet
for a day that's right
2-1 to riley
fouls it back troy gloss by the way 320
career homers he had one season with 47.
yeah he had a big big career
do you think riley is capable of 300
plus in his career and maybe a 45 homer
a year
he's the biggest dude on the team 6-3
240. he's certainly talented enough that
i mean you got to hang around a long
time to put up those kind of numbers
i know your number because it's nice and
clean career 100.
it took me 16 years to get 100.
chopped foul
it's funny though i was blessed to be
drafted by the atlanta braves to kind of
walk into that clubhouse and just expect
to win
from day one
and then on the flip side to go over to
the nationals in 2012 and kind of go in
davey johnson's office and tell them can
i address the team because i don't think
they realize they're ready to win yet
two different
scenarios
two different organizations at two
different times you were part of the
beginning of the rise for the nationals
19 year old bryce harper
anthony rendon was on field two getting
loose
yeah
a walk around spring training
and i was just blown away with how much
talent was on those back fields
payoff to riley
got him
[Applause]
are you ticked if you're riley on that
pitch gets a good pitch right there
maybe a little down
you got second and third anything close
john lester
you're not looking to walk in that
situation i want some ribs
that's what dave martinez wants to see
in the nationals
work that bottom of the zone although i
think nowadays with so many uppercut
swings isn't that the nitro zone for
many players
mike trout loves that pitch
mike trout
it's on a whole other level i mean how
how much of a rabbit hole you want me to
go down here with the way these guys are
swinging there's only one out so
runners are
in scoring positions until you eliminate
the shift you're going to continue to
have guys trying to drive the ball out
of the yard
there's no knocks on the ground josh
donaldson told you that about eight
years ago and and people weren't
listening
and what you're doing now is you're
incentivizing the 678 guy in your lineup
to try and hit homers as well
i don't want him to hit homers i want
him to set the tone for my three four
five and my two three four
you got to give him a reason to change
the way he
prepares
coming into spring training
swinging a miss from swanson josh
harrison what did you think of that k
pitch from lester to riley
borderline
borderline
me not borderline
is he listening
sounds like he is
does he have a little earpiece
[Applause]
here's my thing though
you take the box off the screen that's
not borderline
that's a strike all day long that's an
executed pitch down in the zone hollow
of the knee
i don't think you can have a gripe even
if you go back and watch that on video i
don't think austin reilly is going to
come back to the dugout i think he was
squeezed
[Applause]
i need
about 10 more sound bites today from
josh harrison to feel satisfied because
he could probably be the third man
yeah
when you're done josh take your time but
when you're done
come hang with us
on the media side please do it mid game
yeah
lester went five innings in his 2021
debut five scoreless 70 pitches
but you figure what's the number if he
gets out of this one and
gets back into a groove can he go
90-ish oh yeah oh yeah
and he gets swanson
back-to-back punch-outs for john lester
and he's up to four on the day
again that nasty cutter in he's kind of
been working dance me swans and that's
his second a b he's going cut her in
back door cutter gets him leaning in
just consistently trying to move the
plate
you ever been in john's presence
scott i have the mountain of a man he's
a big dude big dude
i mean throwing half of these pitches
with his tush in his legs so i think he
could stay in there as long as he wants
that's sent to center and that's gonna
fall and score at least one for atlanta
second on its way head for slide azuna's
in there
andreyanza scores two for the braves
make it three nothing
as all bees and azuna come home
we'll make sure zuna's okay i want to
see the replay on the slide
[Applause]
he lays out
aggressive base running for marcel
lazuna coming home and he was hustling
from the jump
[Applause]
yeah i say something here just being
fundamental it's easy from the booth but
that
it's kind of on yon gomez right there
he's got to hold his position victor
robles is one of the best center
fielders in baseball
ball travels faster than you going to
get the ball and bring it back i think
if he's hugging the plate and just gives
ozuna a lane right there that ball gets
to him and he's able to cut down that
run
great slide by marcel how's the arm
sleeve
he has probably got
a crate of like eight thousand of them
give me a new arm sleeve
[Applause]
christian pache cuts and misses
he's in an o2 hole
andreyanza coming up big today at the
hot corner driving in two with the base
hit and then he moves to second on the
throw
braves have been big on that early in
the season
they lead the major 70 runs scored with
two outs adrian's a spot start comes up
with a huge two ribby knock right there
their bench has been pretty good pablo
done great start
you need these guys adriana can play 15
different positions
occasionally get you to knock go deep
had a monster spring he was deserving
went out won a job and then pablo
sandoval
has a knack for the big moment he just
does
and everybody likes to in the clubhouse
great nickname
fun dude
hits good pitching
bad pitches
former world series mvp for the giants
there he is
[Applause]
he's chilling
yeah he'll go down to snit around the
seventh
just let me know when you need me
and that's in there so lester does pick
up three strikeouts he didn't love that
one that's a ball okay
three k's in the inning for leicester
but three runs in the fourth for atlanta
to jump ahead mid four as we head to
break we take a closer look at aussie
albies in this mlbpa infield chatter
feature
the day ozzy albee's turned nine years
old he got to meet his baseball hero it
wasn't my birthday my dad surprised me
with him i don't know how he got in
contact with him 11 years later on the
day of his major league debut andrew
jones surprised him again he was the
first guy andy jones was the first guy
from curacao that came and celebrate and
tell tommy congrats in the dog in
atlanta i love that jones was mlb's
first star from curacao
and the reason alby's and his family are
lifelong braves fans
but it was alby's other hero who led him
to fall in love with baseball in the
first place alby's father who taught
ozzie the game had a heart attack and
died at 41.
his life lessons live on it's amazing
how
how
what he told me before he passed away
always never give up on my dream if it
wasn't because of him i'm not sitting
here today ozzy albee's is who he is in
large part because of his two role
models one a former brave star who loves
watching him play
the other a proud father who never got
the chance
and that's half of the fourth coming up
as this game is live globally on youtube
scott braun and mark derosa and let's
pay off our second poll question best
home run celebration of the last five
years i won you nailed it marcelo zuna
with a good one it's great it's creative
it's relevant when he did it the other
day they were losing like eight two and
he popped it out i was a little like
i don't know but if you're in the dugout
you're cracking up because you're like
that's a zuna being a zuna
and starting to find something hey you
know who had the best week i think of
anyone in major league baseball our next
guest live on youtube max scherzer
joining us max it's scott brown and mark
derosa first off congratulations
derek delivered right after your
complete game and here's first pitch
from starlin castro to dansby swanson so
one out in the bottom of the fourth how
are you today congrats how's the
addition to the family
hey thanks for having me on yeah it's
been a crazy couple days here but uh a
good crazy so
everybody's good and healthy so the
families just got bigger
max i want to ask you it's derosa here i
want to ask you the other day against
the marlins
obviously dominant again
when do you know euron are you a guy
that like the bullpen matters when
you're coming out are you a guy that
needs fastball command is there one or
two pitches kind of take me inside the
mindset like when you turn to yourself
into third or fourth and it's like all
right i got it
i don't know
i i don't know i've thrown enough games
where i feel like i have it then all of
a sudden you go out there and you you
think you got it and then you make a
couple mistakes and wham wham it you
give up a three-run shot so uh you can
never really get you can never really
fall into the
the train of thought that you you're
locked in uh because so many things can
happen in a blink of an eye and it kind
of backwards can work you can be you can
give up you know some early runs but
then settle in and pitch you know you
can go deep in the game throw seven
innings and do something great for your
team so
you know i've tried to kind of get out
of that mindset of hey i need results or
however the game's unfolding to execute
the next pitch
we have some youtube creators with some
excellent questions i feel like i know
the answer to this one but i'll throw it
your way hey max this is from austin
what is your favorite accomplishment of
your career i know winning a world
series is probably up there what about
after that okay that makes more sense no
hitter 20 strikeout games cy young
um i mean obviously young's those are
really really really really cool um but
i really love that 20 strikeout game
more than the no hitter
that was
uh yeah definitely more than no hitters
uh
you know that's a short list and uh
you know when you're out there
that that game was uh i think it was
special even the fans it really fed off
the energy of the fans too so uh yeah
that's one of my favorite
accomplishments
max i want to ask you in today's
generation i mean you played
with a little bit more grizzled veterans
and you're seeing all these guys
backflip and do all these things what is
your take on it
i don't see many guys flipping the bat
to the sky off you i'm not trying to get
you in trouble what's your take if it's
honoring their team and getting them
going
you're cool
um i'm cool as long as it you're it's a
it's just an emotional part of the game
that's just
you know we're humans and if you hit a
big home run in a big spot
you know flip it back whatever that's
you know i could get it you know there's
big spots in the game but i mean if
you're losing and you start bat flipping
that's kind of when i have an issue yeah
um you know then you're just trying to
bring attention to yourself like no it's
a team game so i understand when you hit
you do something great for a team and
you really
you know make a winning player or
anything i mean pitchers you know
pitchers striking somebody out or
defensive play or whatever it is i mean
play with emotion that's fine i get that
uh
you know it's the other stuff that yeah
kind of irritates me
after the one-hour walk from josh bell
it's jan gomes here in the fourth
and takes it inside we're talking to max
scherzer right now okay so max one more
back to the new edition of the family
derek your third child and the real mvp
this week we know as you say your better
half
erica but what's the bigger adrenaline
rush pitching a world series game or
gunning it over to the hospital in the
car two hours after you're tell the
truth max tell the truth
[Laughter]
oh
it's the world series you got adrenaline
for both of them um
i mean you're anxious for both like you
know when you're driving to the hospital
like you're you're anxious you can't
wait for this to happen it's the same
thing i mean it's kind of the same
feeling the world series start you're
anxious as heck to get to the park and
go out there and pitch so kind of
similar feeling even though they're
completely different things
um
come on fall in john gomes floater and
pache is one of the best in the biz
future gold gloves hey max max did you
know did you know or were you surprised
boy or girl on what
yeah we knew a boy was coming yeah yeah
we knew a boy was coming we knew it was
gonna be derek so
uh you know we've had we've had derek
lined up you know we had two girls first
uh but we have always known if we had
boy who's gonna be named eric so uh you
know
good things happen i feel like when i
watch you
i don't want to compare you to tom brady
but tb12 i'm let me think in ms-31 are
we gonna are we pitching into our late
into our 40s what are we doing
uh who knows you're always one injury
away from never playing again so never
like to think too far in the future uh i
kind of just like taking it year by year
let's go out there and uh just stay in
the moment you know can i keep the
blinders up and just go out there and do
do my thing and then
the rest will just take care of itself
one-on-two ads it's kyle schwarber
here's one from stark raving sports hey
max what's one thing about you or your
game that we don't see or know much
about that you'd like to be
more
discussed that's a good question
oh
i don't know
i feel like everybody talks about a
little bit about everything
um
i don't know what you guys think i'll uh
i'll ask you why do you like why things
underrated why do you throw your
bullpens in full uniform
ah this is a good one um so the old
universe when they're made by majestic
they used to give us beefy tops
and uh you know so i used to just throw
the bullpens in the bp tops well then
once they uh they stopped making those
bp tops um
and so i didn't want to just throw them
in like a uh in a dry fit
um yeah i wanted i kind of i kind of
like having to wait on me like a jersey
uh so the only thing that made sense to
me that was actually you just put on a
jersey so now that nike's making these
jerseys again maybe hopefully they make
a bb tops today
schwerberg rips one into the corner
and that's the base second third here we
go and bell heading to third now he's
gonna come home it's bobbled in the
corner josh bell's gonna score as the
nats break the ice schwarber ends up at
third and it's three to one
i know how max is too if this inning
goes forever he's gonna stay with us we
did this once a couple years ago
remember max your team was on probably
don't remember but your team was on a
roll and i remember i was like hey it's
been like 15 minutes you're good and
you're like i'm not leaving now
well we don't talk about stuff like that
yeah
you want jinx i don't jinx things that's
right
max how's it been how's it been having
john lester spring training and then i
know it's been kind of hit or miss with
the kovitz stuff but how's it been
interacting with him yeah
he's just he's just happy to be out of
cover timeout yeah he's back with a club
and he can feel normal be one of us
so after start gave a nice big hug and
said welcome to the team now you can
feel normal again
he enjoys it so he enjoys being back in
the dugout and just being one of us and
just kind of getting back in the flow of
us and you know it's nice to have that
you know he's the only guy that's older
me so i i like having the old guys
by the way on that play for schwarber
it's a double no rbi of course scores
the run in belts three to one talking to
max scherzer here
live on youtube to a global audience
schwarber at third and victor robles
moves the count to 2-0 okay max one
other underrated component i'll bring
this in i believe this is one of your
things talking to hitters as much as
possible about what's going through
their mind am i accurate on that one
that you have conversations that kind of
help you formulate a game plan
um i want to say necessary to form a
game plan but just understand what's
going on
so yeah talking to hitters is great but
i also love talking to hitting coaches
because that they're the ones that are
preaching everything and
you know they're hitting you know k long
here i mean i've
he's been on the other side and had to
prepare against me so many different
times
uh so it's really good picking his mind
of like what he sees how he sees the
game what they're trying to teach
that's why i actually love the nl here
because i get the hit so i'm in the cage
working on that stuff and getting to
hear like what they're trying to teach
how they're talking about contact points
all this stuff uh so the more i'm around
the kind of hitters and hitting coach
and doing that
little shadows he can't see it
that uh you get a feel for what the
hitters do it makes you a better pitcher
that's right john lester gets to hit
right now in a big spot runners on the
corners for washington
and schwarber and roblox he can swing a
little bit
hey max i was talking about that off the
top of the show i said he started his
career over 66.
how terrible is that yep
well it was i think i faced him when he
was like over 62
and thinking he was just going to be
awful and so i just laid in a heater and
he and wrigley like absolutely smashed
it way to the track and like thankfully
we had this interference played right
there i was blown away like
you know i i actually saw i told him
about that i was like i thought you
really you know really stunk but you
like smash it off me like what's this
about and he's like no i can actually
swing a little bit and somehow i was
just in the funk for like a year he
plays golf the exact same way hits it
350 and then it takes a left-hand turn
at around 300 yards and disappears into
someone's backyard
that's good to know
2-0 on its way
from smiley
and he went around
so what's the mindset coming into with
the fans back i gotta believe 2020 you
just kind of that was a wash that had to
be completely strange and odd playing in
front of no one so
get back at it with some fans and get
stung yeah it's yeah it's great having
fans back in the stands uh it's just the
atmosphere the buzz
everybody feels that energy
oh gosh
damn
about launch that one
um
you know just having the fans back i
mean this is what baseball's like i mean
majority baseball we have fans in the
park so it's great to see all the
stadiums fans back and hopefully as the
season goes on we continue to get more
and more yeah youtube creator jolly
olive wants to know does max have a
favorite defender that played behind him
he's got
that's a good one um
there we go
anthony rendon is really good um at
third austin jackson was really good in
center
jose glacier's really good at short
jose iglesias i had a little bit at
short he did some cool things
uh zim's really good at first
um you know who i actually really liked
was miggy um
not that he was great but he worked his
absolute tail off to be the best he
could
and
john lester's a strikeout victim all
right max we got one though and we
appreciate it appreciate it
thanks and congrats on the new edition
max sures are with us live on youtube
his team gets a run it's 3-1 atlanta
after four and that's part
[Music]
and now the battle that everyone has
been waiting for this will be fun
freeman versus rizzo this is going to be
a grenathon right here with these two
i mean
the smile says it all and freddie's
smiling right back at him
i mean if he can get the smile off his
face long enough i say there's no way he
doesn't take him deep
[Applause]
that sweeps off the play one ball those
strikes
1-0 pitch high and away two balls no
strikes
2-1 that's not packed
i guarantee you rizzo's dream to this
freddy strikes out he's never going to
hear the end of this two balls two
strikes
oh he struck him out
look at russo he can't believe it
[Applause]
ah it's great
anthony rizzo just struck out freddie
freeman does something that no other cub
pitcher has been able to do all night
long look at freddie's reaction
[Music]
is jack flaherty really the best nba 2k
player in the league and what does he
and benny feldstein have in common get
to know more about jack on the season 2
premiere of stacked available tomorrow
on youtube.com
mlb
the live game commentary is one of my
best friends here on youtube mlb braves
nationals accounts the youtube creators
that were helping us out with questions
for max scherzer and ian anderson
thoughts questions comments you can see
those
on your mobile on your tv on your
computer and i'll call this out now to
youtube creators because d-row loves
this if you have questions for d-ro
throw them in there
if there's time
at certain spots i will throw them at
zero i know you love that and then maybe
even a few in the post game as well you
know what i don't like jeff mathis going
to left but there's a man there in kyle
schwarber i don't like these shadows
as a hitter
wow
john lester standing in the sunshine
throwing cutters and change-ups you have
tough time if it's perfect conditions
take a look at that mr smiley is just
fighting for dear life
we saw that with lester and his at-bat
last half
four o'clock eastern start time
today
ultra smiley also has a little john
lester
and he's he doesn't have a good time
for 28 career
still has a way to go
you got to get a big league knock though
push something the other way
big inning for atlanta was the fourth
three runs
adrianza with the 2rbi single
maybe this is why i'm
not in the bigs among them any other
reasons but if i'm a pitcher i'm just
working that pitch count
swing at two strikes
maybe
oh he's gonna sneak a bunt on us
is that the move
trying to push one down the third
baseline
i mean there's room to work with
there's castro
and he hasn't budged
now two strikes
against drew smiley
i know mack sure just said in his
interview he likes hitting
but herein lies the
argument for the universal dh i was
again born and raised in the national
league and a bench player in the
national league
so having the pitcher hit worked for me
because i was constantly getting into
games double switches moving stuff
around so the universal dh for a bench
player
is not optimal but i can understand
to eliminate pitchers injuries
hitting and to get the best nine players
up to the plate
for entertainment purposes i do
understand the argument for the
universal ph
smiley held off
fills up the count and
puts it in play
for castro
two gone
hey there's josh harrison what do you
say
that could have been bad
that could have been bad going to pick
it i called it [ __ ]
but it could have been his acl
yeah
now we're glad he's okay
those shades are strong
cunha jr takes a strike bottom of the
zone
it's quick too he's talking about josh
harrison you go to cover the bag a
little alarm side run from the catcher
throws up the line
and you're taught even youth baseball
what's the most important thing baseball
go get it
[Applause]
lester with two quick strikes on okun
yet
so if josh harrison's a 10 in terms of
the volume of conversing that he does in
the fields
what number did you see yeah i was a
talker you were yeah i was a talker with
the guys getting on base and with my
infield i was definitely at least an
eighth
talking to the umpires
yeah i tried to get a feel it's funny
most of the guys will give you
some conversation at second base there
are a few guys the darren ersteds of the
world chase suddenly craig council very
minimal
if you got a hello you were fired up
didn't council not say a word
yeah he wasn't very verbose there's no
there's no denying that
acuna in the air long run for hernandez
he's there
and he'll head right back to the dugout
after a one two three fifth inning dealt
by john lester his team trailing by a
couple runs mid five
[Music]
[Music]
carrie wood going to the mound for the
cubs today in the conclusion of a
two-game series against the division
leading houston astros
i just really try to take a deep breath
forget what you just did in the bullpen
know that your body's loose and go out
and try to go get them
got him with the heat one down he
changes speeds and bell strikes out
he punched out the order in the first
the ball was coming out nicely that day
just one of those days where i didn't
feel like i could do wrong
got him
seven strikeouts
he struck out eight
see you later
13 strikeouts
what can you say
18
strikeouts first of all i didn't know
the record was 20. and i'm going in the
ninth in and i feel like i can strike
everybody at him
the crowd will tell you the story
i think everybody in the stadium was
coming everybody on tv and it was coming
here comes
[Applause]
[Music]
today marks 411 games that davey
martinez is the national skipper and
today that actually marks that he has
become the longest tenured manager in
their history so we were talking to him
pregame and he said that he didn't even
know until trey turner hugged him and he
told trey are you just in a good mood
today or why are you hugging me so trey
let the guy know you know today you
become the longest tenured manager and
davey looked at him and said if you keep
slugging the way that you are i'll be
your manager for a lot longer
that's a great story savannah thank you
longest tenured manager before davey
just hit 411. manny octa 2007 2009
that's it
this is their guy now little tidbit
his teammates with dave martinez in
atlanta kind of his twilight of his
career it was beginning of mine we were
bench dogs with julio franco and ozzy
guillen
just a wealth of knowledge
going on to learn under joe madden
get his chops there then win a world
series with the cubbies
right man right time i mean there were
talks back you go back to 2019 what were
they 19 and 34 31 19 and 31 there was
talks davey might be replaced
remember we were talking at least on mlb
network sometimes
about trade rumors maybe scherzer oh all
this all this garbage
really went on to have one of the most
epic world series in 2019 no one won a
home game turner wants that swing back
pace for out number one
dave martinez played for 16 seasons
nine teams over 1500 career hits
cool guy broke into the big leagues at
age 21 in 1986 with the cubs hired in
october of 2017 this is season number
four at the helm bench coached with joe
madden for a long time
and there's the career line as a player
and the gnats in 2019
won their first ever world series title
i remember for the brief time before we
hit the pandemic of course dave martinez
said the biggest difference for me since
we won hugs just walking around town i'm
getting hugs just like turner did for
him he's getting hugs from random people
in dc we love you davey
they should that team was special
i think the interesting thing watching
dave martinez and talking to him
hernandez to deep center and bache is
there he covers so much great ground
a few feet away from the wall
nice play talking about interviewing for
managerial positions and not getting
them he said you know i tried to be
joe madden's clone
and he goes when i finally go went into
these uh interviews and not only spoke
about what i believed joe madden did
well but also what how i would be an
individual in the position he said i
felt like
mr rizzo mr lerner they were listening a
lot more and
in turn he ends up
getting a crack at managing and nats and
then winning the world series
first pitch swinging and that is going
to be caught by austin reilly
[Applause]
oh we're going to get one mike yeah josh
harrison we don't turn it around live
but it's coming don't worry
[Applause]
there it is wow austin riley can fly
over at first base doesn't play there
often but doing it well this afternoon
and again drew smiley with a nice frame
one two three in the fit
[Music]
there's always so much excitement and
anticipation prior to game one and for
great reason
two out of nobody on here's ryan
zimmerman the longest tenured national
here's the wide of the pitch swinging a
driving well deep center field way back
goes springer to the warning track
looking up and it is gone
goodbye
so we go to the fourth inning the
nationals trailing two to one it'll be
juan soto facing garrett cole
the 1-0 swinging a fly ball well hit to
left field it's going going and long
going up under the railroad tracks 20
years old and just bursting with power
and the astros are down to their final
out
into left center field robles is there
and the washington nationals have stolen
game one on the road
the gnats if they can win three of their
next six games will win the world series
everybody getting in on the act tonight
12-2 washington well the nationals have
certainly come to houston and flex their
muscles
[Applause]
and that's the ball game a blowout win
here tonight in game two
download the mlb app to get in-game
video highlights live pitch by pitch
breaking news player updates stat
leaderboards and more for your favorite
team and the rest of the league
back to john lester in the sixth scott
braun and mark derosa
savannah mccann with us as well today on
youtube
ozzy albies walked last time up ended up
scoring that was all the action for the
brave the fourth inning
brian snicker thrilled that they're
facing a lefty today
there's one on the outside corner
breaking stuff gets in there but
not doing great work against left-handed
pitching this year small sample size he
owns john lester six for eight a homer
and
you can swing it from the right side i
know that small sample size but that
that is ownership and it continues
seven for nine seven for nine is big
new to the mlb game of the week for the
2021 season the youtube player of the
game fans watching on mobile devices and
computers
later is your chance to vote which
player will receive the trophy during
the post game show stay tuned
for the player of the game polling
options later in the show not only do
you get to decide who receives this
trophy which players are gravitating
towards they're receiving it it gets
their name engraved the whole deal but
also you get to pick who we talked to in
the post game which is okay
who's the early leader adrianza with the
two rbi double
perhaps
here comes dave martinez to take the
baseball
[Applause]
on to the nats bullpen
with marcelazuna coming up for atlanta
in the sixth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
great baseball right
[Applause]
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
and something like this is what they
came for
[Applause]
[Music]
after an albie's hit through the infield
marcelo zuna is going to dig in against
the new pitcher austin both and look
what he brought to the table for the
atlanta braves
a grand slam
against the washington nationals
yesterday in the third inning they
decided to intentionally walk freddie
freeman statcast 3d powered by google
cloud showing us the longest average
distance homer man in baseball since the
start of 2020 it's the man who's about
to hit marcelo zuna averages
433 feet of glory when he connects off
the bat over the wall
you think about it yesterday
freddie's been struggling they put them
on
marcel's like really last year i led the
senior circuit in homers and rbis i was
yelling at the tv when ronald stole
second because it almost forced davey's
hand
listen they've caught lightning in a
bottle you go back to 19 when they
picked up josh donaldson for the
one-year deal and he hit behind freddy
and he was a monster and then they
doubled down on another one-year deal
with ozuna i'm like man he can't keep
getting away with this
well they got away with it again
he has been awesome for this team and
not just and not just in the lineup just
everything he brings
fouls back that pitch from austin both
28 year old right hander mostly four
seamers and curveballs off to a nice
start
both touring runs in 10 and two-thirds
but he's dealing
with one of the nl's best from 2020
who's locked up to a four-year deal in
the offseason for 65 million dollars
with atlanta
and that was an interesting deal there
was a lot of people in atlanta that
thought they were bidding against
themselves i mean no dh in the national
league you saw guys like nelson cruz and
marcelo zuna have to wait out the market
was incredible
18 homers in 60 games yeah sixth place
nlm vp
if you go by ops plus it's not that
complicated of his stat 100 is league
average he was 175 75 better than the
average big leaguer at the plate
that's saying something
and 1-1 tapper back to both he'll go to
second and they'll turn
two that's right bell stays on the back
and a double play for austin both to
race both baits with base runners
[Applause]
i can't tell you how much it means to
the position players when a pitcher can
field their position right here mr voth
turning at 163 you work on this in the
backfields of spring training in a
situation like this where it has to be
made and has to get done he's able to do
it
you played with greg maddox i played
with a few carlos zambrano greg maddox
tom glavin john smoltz there's a bunch
adam wainwright who really took pride in
in the other parts of their game and it
matters picking off the bags holding
runners
being able to pfp cover cover the bags
get buns down
max freed won the gold glove
in the national league last year
dallas kykel is excellent for the white
sox
makes sense too if you
are a ground ball guy you better field
your position well
day off for freeman today
both versus riley
doesn't bite
it has been nice to see austin riley
kind of situate himself into more
comfortability at the plate i mean this
was a guy like i said
you couldn't you couldn't keep him in
the minors any longer and then he came
and played left field and he hit like 12
jacks in 30 games and everyone fell in
love and then there was a huge valley
and then there was the huge homer off
blake trying and last year in the nlcs
it's just you wanted him to find kind of
his sinus rhythm of who he's going to be
i don't think
we truly know yet
nine homers his first 18 career games
there was i remember his father
hitting homers with his dads in the
stands
i watched him in the playoffs last year
not the shiniest line but a lot of loud
contact to center field this time on the
ground to the left side for turner
and there's the inning so after alby's
base hit
and comes austin both for a double play
ball and then a ground ball out from
riley mid-six braves still up by two
this is the 115th world series and for
just the third time in the history of
the fall classic the rogue team has won
each of the first five games tonight
it's the nationals trying to force a
game seven tomorrow night
swings and it's one a deep right down
the line going going good goodbye
bang
soon goes eaton it's the nationals two
and the astros too
so now juan soto
sono swings and hits one high and deep
to right going going
into the top tank a tremendous home run
for juan soto
and a world series game six when a curly
w is in the books they've stayed in the
fight let's finish the fight tonight
nats that is a rocket to left and the
lead is cut in half
about it was howie kendrick and he hits
it down the right field line
and it's gone howie kendrick has done it
again
what a stunner here in game seven
the nationals are a strike away from
that franchise's first ever world series
championship swinging a miss
in a world series game 7 woody curly w
is in the box unbelievable
in the middle of the fourth inning at
nationals parks the racing president
they race each other all around and
craziness always ensues now if you're at
truest park and you're a braves fan you
know that beat the freeze is something
that cannot be missed well now i'm here
to ask you with our youtube poll which
is the more entertaining ballpark staple
beat the freeze
which we'll see right here and this is
always so good
which one do you guys like better up in
the booth there do you like beat the
freeze or the president's race
zero's cracking up thanks savannah
peter freeze is good but but i'm loyal
to the president's race i think it's the
best one
and i got a little back story too go for
it 2012 post season
right before the jason worth epic home
run to force
game five
i read
the man in the arena by teddy roosevelt
i brought in a karaoke machine
a karaoke machine i had a karaoke me and
mike morris had a karaoke machine we
shared a locker we had a karaoke machine
in 2012 with the gnats and we had a lot
of fun with that and i felt like the
guys needed me to read the man in the
arena by teddy roosevelt so while they
were getting ready because i wasn't on
the roster i was damaged goods what
i recited that
unbelievable speech he gave
you were the man on that team jason
worth went deep yeah we ended up losing
the next night that was one that's still
one of the toughest losses
since i've retired i go back to because
that team could have won the whole thing
talent was there oh we're rolling that
team was rolling
straws was locked
geo
straws got shut down had we had him in
the postseason that's a whole nother
story we don't have to go down that that
warm home but
it eventually all worked out in 2019.
starlin castro is a hits machine
he's on for the second time today
we'll see if the nats can get things
going off they're smiling it's been
brilliant and right now your player
spotlight
presented by global citizen facts live
josh bell in the first half of 2019 he
wasn't just an all-star he was that year
he was a superstar since then we haven't
seen the same
everything from josh bell at the plate
that we witnessed in the first half we
thought the next superstar was coming to
the show
big dude
former big time pick from the pittsburgh
pirates a lot of promise in the minor
league switch hitter great kid
great makeup
and
you can see so far this season of buck
45 slow start coming off the covet il
which many gnats dealt with and
hasn't
hasn't clicked like it did in the first
half of 2019 a big swing and miss i know
you've got a lot for me here dear i want
to preface what you bring to the table
with
did the league adjust to him and then
he's not adjusting back yet
it's funny you try and
find ways i look at it a little bit
differently it's almost like the grass
isn't greener on the other side but for
some guys it may be
did he go
chris guccione right there no says he
didn't
my thing is like
driving to the yard every day
what's your motivation playing for the
pittsburgh pirates you know you got no
shot at winning the nl central so you
get real selfish and if you get real
selfish in baseball you start going down
you know some pretty dark paths that if
you're not getting results
you start just
i kind of lead more towards that i want
to give him more of of a time to get his
legs under him in the dc area the
expectations are going to be way bigger
in this nationals uniform pirates are in
a full-blown rebuild
but i yes i can definitely agree with
what you're saying as far as
he made it an effort to get the ball in
the air more start driving the ball out
of the park
riley found the popper
first out in the bottom of the sixth
and now john gomez
yeah bell last year 226 364 slugging but
it's 57 games
a couple months with no fans i mean last
year for these guys they said all the
right things and hats off to baseball
and everyone associated with it for
grinding out the 60 games but now that
we're past that i mean
that's 60 games of
it's whatever
i mean you can't you can't honor the
numbers i mean it's like playing on the
back fields of spring training when no
one's watching
most of the front office execs that i
talk to when they're evaluating a player
for me this year
they're often referring to 2019 or they
take a combo 2019 and 2020. it's just
like adding two more months to their
ledger in the recent past
okay i think it's time more love right
now and i know braves fans are waiting
for it for what drew smiley is doing in
some ways fans are probably like don't
jinx it but hey i don't believe in that
stuff
smiley
throwing to jeff mathis today just like
brian snicker said
might have found himself a personal
catcher five and a third one run three
walks but he's punched out four
i look at it the other way scotty b he
might have found himself a personal
catcher but the expectations on a
one-year 11 million dollar deal for drew
smiley are this
that was some play so turn two
wow
run that back austin riley doing some
work at first
here it is again
goes for second the leap from swanson
touches the bag fires to first
the atlanta braves can pick it
dansby swanson
starting up the double play
and again a scoreless inning for drew
smiley 3-1 atlanta going for the sweep
in d.c
[Music]
jello
it's a plate
oh my god what's this we got another
plate
oh
is it flan
like that
[Music]
latino
is it edible
it is edible
[Music]
rice pudding
jelly
i guess this type of
cheesecake i don't know what is it
flan
cheesecake
strawberry jelly
[Music]
or grape jelly
is that jello
[Music]
we are thrilled to have you with us for
the mlb game of the week live on youtube
presented by global citizen backs live
stream the extended show only on youtube
this saturday at eight o'clock eastern
time and some superstar legendary
performances will be coming your way on
saturday at eight o'clock if you love
music that's the spot to be foo fighters
eddie better jennifer lopez jay baldwin
her and this copyrighted telecast is
presented by authority as the office of
the commissioner of baseball and may not
be reproduced or retransmitted in any
form in the accounts and descriptions of
this game may not be disseminated
without express written consent
i do that once or twice a week so i'm
pretty fast now
dansby swanson turned one heck of a
double play with austin reilly
back in the bottom of the fifth
or make that the bottom of the six now
he leads off to seventh for atlanta
five six and seven coming up
so here's where you want dan's becoming
unglued right here 2-0 looking middle
way heater trying to go opposite field
home
right here double off the right center
gap
thought about it
good paint from both
austin both working his second inning
here
and there's the line 2 for 13 a double
and a homer
against the nats reliever
solid contact to center hanging in the
air and look who's all over it
victor robles wow both center fielders
today putting on a show
[Applause]
[Music]
look at roble's move
[Applause]
[Music]
made that play look easy first step
quickness
he had that throw to the plate on
adrian's bullet up the chute too
outs above average is a great stat to
measure your overall defensive
performance since the start of 2019 it's
kevin curmier and victor robles
i know he led in 2019 role plays as a
rookie
i asked mike grizzo that year i think
he's going to win a gold glove or two
he's like absolutely he goes i think he
should have won it in 2019 but they
don't give them the rookies
adrianza takes
savannah what do you think about the
defensive performance today in center
field
well you talked about that first step
quickness and that's something davey
martinez has picked up on too
last season victor robles came to summer
camp with 20 pounds of muscle on him
because he wanted to get a little bit
bigger davey didn't quite understand but
he told him you know maybe let's lose a
little bit of muscle let's get some
flexibility back in that and i think
that your defense is really going to
improve from that and play like that
just shows you that you may have lost a
little bit of muscle weight there but
that guy can move
agility flexibility
that's what he worked on this past
offseason and we're seeing the 2019 form
out in center fields
they also have him playing a bit further
back
this year so he can run in on the
baseballs
and that's been working out for him as
well they did that with juan soto last
year
i mean he can fly so don't worry
if he needs to come in he'll be there
no one's telling us to stop lifting
we we love it
hey victor robles
doesn't need to lift weights right now
just do this in the series he robbed
ronald acuna jr on tuesday he can lift
when he's done playing
and he's already a strong guy
and they need him to do more of this
last night coming in for the baseball
hey they back them up and they say you
can fly you're good
and then this time coming across
superman action this week
popped up
gomes looking for it and he finds it
[Applause]
and therein lies
getting back to
the shift right you got a guy like
victor robles who wants to come into
camp
not out of shape but in the wrong shape
why
he wants to drive the ball out of the
yard that's what everyone's doing
getting paid for it
it's tempting
and he is a are they all getting paid
for it because it's watered down
the number of homers so you're you're
still you're seeing the mega guys get
paid
if it's the middle man that'll
eventually get squeezed out
and center field is tough to find at the
elite level defensively as we see the
counterpart for the braves pache
a ball and no strikes but
a good example would be lorenzo kane
five years 80 million bucks a few years
back
set your sights on a player like that if
you're pache or robles
that's good though
yeah you can make it more if we can make
it work with that yeah
these are two of the finest center
fielders in the biz they're just young
so
on the national stage
i think fans are still learning about
the tools yeah
also in addition to the range that
apache has he might have the best arm in
major league baseball because it's not
just strong it is incredibly
precise listen any prospect that's going
to come through as an outfielder in the
braves organization is going to be
compared to one guy and one guy one guy
alone that's andrew jones
kind of the best to ever do it i know
it's willie mays's 90th birthday but you
can argue andrew was as good as him
sprint speed right there 27.9 just
that's who he's been compared to andrew
comes down to spring training and puts
the uniform on and kind of that outfield
guru and his work with pasha over the
years and it's funny you talk about
robles playing deeper
man i felt like when i was playing
shortstop second base back in the late
90s early 2000s andrew was like
breathing on my neck
because greg max smalty those guys he
wanted though they wanted those knocks
taken away blooper in december yeah
jones is there they beat you over the
over your head it's on me
and he got him
austin both with the strikeout so
it's a nice defense behind him in center
field and then he strikes out the brave
center fielder
perfect seventh from the nats reliever
[Applause]
sway gonna miss betty cutting one got
him on the hook the win for eric fetty
with five scoreless innings the
nationals have won
three in a row
[Applause]
scherzer stealing and there's no play
he just got a walking lead and kept on
going
check it out folks standing ovation at
the ballpark max scherzer first career
stolen base
[Applause]
and there's a look at the 22 year old
make his major league debut another
left-hander patrick corbin carves up
giancarlo's nice change-up
we're going to miss patrick corbin
inside corner panda ramirez is run up
and that is how this game ends in
patrick corbin's major league debut
all season long major league baseball
will honor frontline and essential
workers who continue to lift up their
fellow citizens during the pandemic
thank you frontline heroes
we stretched and we have another pole
result to bring you
nice and easy here more entertaining
signature race beat the freeze braves
fans showing a big on the poles today 68
president's race
with 32a
both
highly entertaining in their own ways
you know one involving
four
very unique mascots that make a ton of
sense being that it's in dc and then
beat the freeze just came out of nowhere
what four or five years ago
and uh went viral really i mean after
that race what was it maybe the first
one or one of the first oh yeah when the
when the guy thought he had him
starting to milk it celebrate a little
all of a sudden you look back you fall
and a legend was born
while we're messing around it's the
bottom of the seventh that mr smiley's
still in there yeah
he's looking like your player of the
game
seven eight nine in the order for the
nationals
one and one to kyle schwarber
so
i watched his last start tom glabin was
on the broadcast he actually said too
many strikes expand the strike zone
we've got the fastball up the breaker
low which we're seeing today and the
fastball down in their first strike you
heard me talk about that scotty b
one of my takes it almost becomes swing
mode you almost think you can hit
everything he's throwing so to tommy's
defense if you are in the zone too much
this that's when he will get hurt
and tommy would know
he worked those edges
as well as anyone we've ever seen drew
smiley has not completed seven innings
since september 7th of 2019.
pitch counts at 93. his season high is
94 in his first outing of the year
against the nationals where he went six
[Applause]
you know the braves are his fifth
organization since 2019. he's hopped
around hasn't been the same guy since
coming back from tommy john surgery
really a number of injuries for him in
the last five years didn't pitch at all
in 2017 we're 18.
missed 324 games
payoff
we'll do another but you could look at
that also as a guy who has a lot left in
the tank and hasn't been used a ton in
the past few years
listen there's some funkiness to him
there's some late life to his fastball
there's some swing and miss
if you throw left handed you can run it
up there you know
they'll keep you around
his foreseemer was getting crushed
before today's outing there's luke
jackson apparently
the funniest guy on the atlanta braves
ian anderson told us earlier
right he gave a bike tour
to some of the other pitchers the
monuments on the off day
good a b by schwarber he's battling
what are you going with here
oh you can't walk him i i mean schwarz
is the kind of guy he wants to hit his
way on but he does have good vision i
mean if you're going to throw a breaking
ball it's got to get it's got to have to
play for 59 feet i mean i'm going heater
down and away just the same as jeff
mathis
missed
lead off base runner for the nationals
in the seventh
short
he knocks out the starter too drew
smiley with a big day for atlanta
i bet you he's going for a lefty
are there any righties in the bullpen
jackson what he's calling
that's it
usually you're accurate with that guess
this time yes it's a righty coming in
for the braves
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
then the swing and a miss and then that
goes all the way out it's fair shallow
right field
that is good distance the bat head hit
fair and then the handle hit foul so
we're gonna call that a fair not a fair
ball that's a fair bat
for one pitch here's a swing and a high
upper behind home plate murphy trying to
pick it out of the dome got tangled up
with the umpire adrian johnson and
somehow made the catch first base umpire
john barbour says yes in a ring
and that's a dead hole
what a job by sean murphy and all for
nothing a little while ago
covered up our camera
saw the towel was gone
towels off
still staring down the
camera now he wants to go hide
dad don't look
watch
[Music]
rizzo versus freeman he wants to punch
him out so bad
[Music]
[Music]
luke jackson is in for atlanta to face
eighth place hitter victor robles scott
brown mark derosa and our third analyst
today is actually playing on the fields
his name's josh harrison
he's gonna be good
i mean he is good
when he figures it out
out there is
stupid
ah
damn
off the bat it looked like it was going
too high
thank you josh
for all of your words of wisdom today
seriously though
fun teammate to have
and roblaise pulls back on the bunt
from luke jackson so i was joking hey
it's probably a lefty no it's a righty
but
you just don't see this
from bullpens these days and jackson off
to a really hot start out of the pen
this is his 12th appearance but
the braves have more lefties than
righties
in their bullpen
and it's something that i think has to
be addressed as the season progresses
that's through the left side and robles
is in business schwarber up to second
that's putting the pressure on jackson
in the seventh
[Applause]
how do you address that trade a couple
we're just gonna have to go out
find a way oh well chris martin's gonna
be on the mend obviously
shocked i saw marco lansing just signed
for one year 2 million with the san
diego padres i thought he was a perfect
fit to come back
shane green's just still at home working
out
mats fans
on their feet for juan soto here we go
at bat of the day
you can't play the field yet
[Applause]
crowhop drills mock throws on tuesday
thrown to the bases yesterday he'll dh
this weekend
interleague affair against the yankees
in the bronx and then they hope to have
him back in the field next week
two on
yeah
[Music]
technically
where was that
i guess we got that up i mean you
watched luke jackson throw i mean this
guy is a 51
slider
39 four-seamer so you're you're hunt
breaking ball more than you're sitting
on on a heater with this guy soto hasn't
been a pitch hitter often in his career
he's usually playing starting one for
six as a pinch hitter
with a home run
[Applause]
see now you're in a tough situation if
you're luke jackson i mean you do you
really want to get back in this count
are you really trying to give him a home
run to hit right here you know you got
trey turner on deck
this is where you put brian snicker in a
tough position with the way his bullpen
is constructed
[Applause]
2-0
soto connects
left field
azuna back and he's on it
and both runners retreat
that's a big out
now luke jackson with some confidence
back to the mounds
he had to get back in that count he
challenged him
2-0 nice play by marcelo zuna going into
the corner right here
one gone top of the order it's trey
turner
[Music]
that's your soto ap of the day
hey
two on down couple runs
that's where you wanted him
trey is hitless today
and takes a strike
it is funny you think back now you know
going to break if you know soto's the
bullet that's going to get spent right
there kind of leads you to think
i think along with the manager
you have all those lefties i was kind of
shocked luke jackson was your call same
here
that could be two gotta be quick to
first trey beats it out
the force at second and schwarbers to
third
so they're on the corners for yadiel
hernandez
and i can't tell you how much that means
to watch number seven trey turner get
down the line right there we all assume
he's gonna beat out to double play but
you do still keep the inning alive and
this is a nice matchup for mr hernandez
against luke jackson
sprint speed best in baseball
tied with tim lo castro of the
diamondbacks
i mean you really gotta get a
tailor-made double play ball and be
perfect in your execution to beat him
check that scotty b i mean that's nine
and a half out of ten big leaguers are
out there
i'm shocked
you know he's bounced into five double
plays this year
he's hitting everything on the screw
that's true
[Applause]
it has to be a rocket
to shorter second
hernandez had the single in the third
[Applause]
2-0 from jackson that's a little pitch
right there
[Music]
over 162 you got to get away with
situations like this
you get into the postseason this matchup
will never present itself there's a
left-hander in no matter what in this
situation
hernandez on the ground right side for
all beasts great job by luke jackson
and he wiggles out first to reach for
the nationals nothing to show for it
luke jackson battling through a little
bit of traffic his team's up two after
seven
the fastball
the fastball
was right down right down
the
pipe
the pipe
perfect
pumpkin puppy
no
pumpkin
bobby
pumpkin
pup
pump pup ken
and
can pumpkin
popcorn oh my god
you're you're doing you pumpkin
pie
i'm from texas yes pumpkin
pumpkin pumpkin
pumpkin
pup
ken puppy
can poppin pop poppin what's poppin hey
yo what's poppin pumpkin spice latte is
this the same one spiced latte same
thing pumpkin spice latte if you don't
get anyone the next one
can't read
pumpkin spice latte
nope next one next one
[Music]
go behind the scenes watch exclusive
interviews and series and learn more
about your favorite players on the
atlanta braves youtube channel head to
youtube.com braves and follow the braves
today
covet 19 vaccines are safe and effective
join the team and get the vaccine to
help get us all back to doing what we
love together visit mlb.com hobit 19
resources for more
well in the information section jolly
olives said this seems like a do or die
inning if the gnats want to win this we
just saw them with two on could not
convert
they'll have two more cracks at the
braves bullpen coming up but first it's
the braves turn to try and add some
insurance against the new man daniel
hudson summoned into the game
34 years old
known for
some big innings in 2019 for the nats
making his ninth appearance of the
season era in the low twos
first it's jeff mathis swinging at 96.
[Applause]
you know mathis playing today but
william contreras is now the big man
behind the plate for the braves he'll be
the regular catcher until travis darneau
comes back which might not be until the
end of the season contreras is four for
ten with a homer younger brother of
wilson who plays on the cups
mathis with a little bunt down the first
base side but there's hudson with the
underhand toss for out number one
i like william contreras yeah
and and you see listen
the reason jeff mathis mathis has been
able to stay in the game as long as he
has because he honors the pitching staff
first worries about his offense second i
think that's what the great catchers
have to do they have to get their
pitching staff to buy into the fact that
blocking balls and putting digits down
are more important than you know hitting
a three-run bomb
and that's what you
seeing all the remarks from the braves
pitching staff they seem to really love
throwing to
this guy has some swagger too panda time
pablo sandoval
in a month's work with the braves has
made a name for himself
four for 14 three homers yeah there's
some swing and miss but there's some run
production he's such a better athlete
than people people have any clue i mean
this guy i i get it his weight's been
chronicled and it's fluctuated back and
forth up and down
he's an athlete there's not much panda
can't do on a baseball field
throws with both hands can hit from both
sides could probably go behind a dish
and catch again if he wanted to
not going to cheat him on his axe
grabs the helmet back three pinch hit
homers in april most by a braves player
in any calendar month ever
hudson brings the 1-2
you talk about it with snicker today
about bullpen rolls
and i know you want 26 hybrids
guys who can do pretty much anything
but guys are creatures of habit would
like to assimilate into some type of
role the same can be said for the bench
i mean you got a guy like adrianza kind
of knows when he's getting a spot start
where he's going in the panda knows
exactly he's going to be summoned to
have these he's going to get their
toughest pinch hit at bats all year long
charlie culberson had some big at-bats
the last few years for the braves
braver braves have always been an
organization that is steadfast on their
their backup infielder being able to
play short and that be his primary
position
you saw it with it dani echeveria you
saw it all go all the way back to
raphael bellyard so the culversons of
the world that can moonlight at
shortstop eventually they want to get
away from that in case a dansby had to
come out
wisely daniel hudson lets it go past his
bare hands
and sandoval grounds out
you don't want that
i mean they have orlando garcia sitting
at the alternate site
that's true
there's turner
yeah garcia
cut loose by the brewers and dealt
over to atlanta and
he's a fine defender
[Music]
tugan in the eighth back to acuna
remember we were hanging out with the
cuny and albies in spring training three
or four years ago yeah and they were
trying to make the beast a thing for his
nickname i like it
but i haven't heard it no it's never it
had no legs why because he doesn't look
like a beast but he plays like a beast
but he's a swaggy beast
the gold beast
he's just was put on this earth to play
baseball uh you know to make it look
pretty the way he makes it look
i know you talked about this too
hitting coach kevin seitzer saying the
big adjustment this year
he would lose the barrel in the past
leading to some whiffs and
it would drop below the ball not stay on
an even plane
lines that one up
right center
and it's hernandez making the call
[Applause]
nice and easy for daniel hudson in the
eighth
back to the nats bats
in the bottom of the frame down by two
runs
nice day from the men on the mound this
afternoon braves going for the sweep
a book club was something that i kind of
started last year we have a couple of
really good titles that i'm excited for
so you know hopefully we can get as many
people involved as possible
the girls in my life my mom
my aunt my sister my grandmother they
were always reading they finally got me
to sit down and read a little bit and
you know started to blossom as a hobby
of my own over the years
for the titles of
the book club
they're more
based around books that i wish i had
read earlier um books that you know i
read and i was like man i could have
used this four or five years ago so i
think that everybody's going to get
something out of it and everybody's
going to be very thankful you know once
they finally close the book for the
final time for me this year i think that
kind of diving inside
us as people and i think that everybody
has the opportunity to grow everybody
should try to get 1-0 every day so
hopefully this is an opportunity for us
to do that
i want this to be as inclusive as
possible so you know anybody that wants
to log on to the webinar ask questions
you know this is what the book club's
for i'm here for you i'm going to be
reading as well so
you know come on let's do it
every fan wants to leave the ballpark
with a bit of a souvenir and last night
josh harrison made it happen for a young
fan all game long the fan was yelling
please throw me a ball throw me a ball
and josh harrison was trying and they
just couldn't connect the ball to the
glove but when andrew stevenson got out
to right field josh harrison made sure
that there was a ball for that young fan
and post game josh harrison went out and
signed it so that fan definitely has a
souvenir and i guess a josh harrison fan
of her life thanks for the photo too
savannah that's a great story and i like
the handoff from harrison to stevenson
to give him the baseball last night
he's
doing it all this week
handing out baseballs giving us
a miced up day
josh harrison one for three
he has a stolen base back in the first
they need him to be a spark in the
eighth and that was actually relevant
for his nickname in pittsburgh clint
hurtle called him microwave
it's a good nickname also underrated
probably
troy piston that's right
edgar santana
new reliever 29 years old
what i noticed about josh harrison
scotty is that his top hand and bottom
hand are actually disconnected at the
plate when he's holding the bat you
don't see many guys there's actually
like a little half inch space in between
almost like forcing himself to kind of
throw that top hand at the baseball
that mitt would
bother me
on the left hand no
did you have
a batting glove like that he he's
obviously been drilled in the hand a ton
yeah probably suffered a frack him he's
swinging a bat nice
it's a deep center and then
will watch it
off the wall
and harrison is going to slide into
second with a lead-off double
oh if it went just to shade left it was
gone but high part of the wall in right
center field for harrison
and he's got two bags out of him
[Applause]
i'm sure he's going really a little
two-seam fastball coming back over the
heart of the plate doesn't cheat to it
drives it up the middle the other way oh
man i mean
like you said
a foot left and it's a homer oh
another foot
vertically and it's a homer too that's
all right getting a rally going yeah
that sets up starlin castro double
number four on the year yeah harrison
swinging the bat well
two hits today
harrison is excuse me castro has reached
base
two out of three times this afternoon
four-time all-star at the plate
boy
[Applause]
edgar santana just made his braves debut
on friday
relieving drew smiley
and smiley watching him very carefully
now again today
got to get him back in the count right
here i mean starlin is going to
potentially obviously take one
potentially take two
and force this young
right-hander to get back into count
maybe put even more pressure on them
minter and matsik two of the big guns
out of the bullpen have pitched in each
of the last two games we're still early
in the season coming off an abbreviated
campaign in 2020 so
if you're a braves fan and you're
sitting you're watching you're going
where's
where are we going
that's the right matchup only problem is
starlin castro is a guy who has
north of 1600 hits
led the nl 2011 with 207 hits
ball four
four misses from santana
[Applause]
so harrison with the near homer instead
it's a double traffic brewing here in
the eighth but harrison almost had it
man
wrong part of the park
[Applause]
i ain't got no pop
i ain't got no pop
that's gone probably like 27 other parks
tell you where it ain't gone here in
detroit
you know there's actually a stat now
where we can look up how many parks
where it would have been gone so i'll
get you that
oh four
just four
it stays at four yards
what
no wait it's gone in four stays in four
minutes no it only stays home run in
four it's only a home run in four that's
right bell to left
wow that's hanging up for a while azuna
puts him away and a tag up
and he's there harrison to third
there's no home run hitter but he's got
speed
just one out runner at third
and castro's at first and there's this
situation you don't want to take the bat
out of joshua bell's hands you don't
want him to be
not go to the plate aggressive but you
just watch him walk starlin castro on
four pitches you're scuffling he's
scuffling to find his own
take a pitch
i don't know if i necessarily take a
pitch i
need your helmet falling off if you're
gonna swing at the first one
[Applause]
john gomes oh for three
and on the hands and that's foul
watch exclusive content on the
washington nationals youtube channel
head to
youtube.com nationals and follow the
gnats today
[Applause]
harrison double castro walk
bell flew out to left
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't let the braves get off the
hook with luke jackson and mr
santana back to back innings
have to find a way to scratch someone
across i know he's down 02.
john gomez more than capable of working
himself back into this count santana
with a scoreless sixth inning last night
one walk 15 pitches
gomes
out to right center and he's in business
and the gnats cut this to a one run game
harrison trots home it's 3-2
[Applause]
that's gonna do it for santana john
gomez connects
take a look at this 02 great slider
actually
just a nice piece of hit by yon gomes
bad head to the baseball right there
just pushing it the other way grabbing
himself a
gets the job done castro at second
goals will hang it first santana will
come out of the game and lead us to
grant dayton coming out of the bullpen
there's your lefty for atlanta next
[Applause]
now let's see ronald gafflin so we can
see the big fella run no just hit in the
seats
[Applause]
the ball is absolutely hammered
glad you called it the seat
[Music]
[Applause]
has put the braves in front yeah take a
selfie marcel and the grand tour well
right on cue chip you talk about the
struggles with the breaking ball you
talk about the extra work they've been
putting in and it pays off i want to let
that go as long as it can but like we
talked about
fly ball felt it he's back long home run
how far up the fleet uses that goal
so his first hit since april 17
481 feet for acuna
that was worth being interrupted
that ball was hammered
google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball
statcast powered by google cloud
with two home runs this season from kyle
schwarber and a common theme
both bombs 450 plus both
walk-off shots for the nets
it's quality over quantity right now
d-ro
you said he looks felt he looks great he
can
really
smash the baseball a long way and we've
seen that for years down 20 20 but again
short season 2019 was a career year 38
homers 92 driven in
[Applause]
he was going for it there
breaking pitch from grant dayton he is
really one of the guys when i watch and
i look around the league kind of that
enigma in the box because he does so
many things fundamentally right it's not
like he's got long arms or i mean he's
short and quick to the baseball what he
did in 16 to come back from the blown
out knee and be relevant have relevant
abs in the world series was like
legendary
yeah good play this is a much slump in
his game
he had 412 in the world series in 2016.
three hits in game seven
he was having a beas against andrew
miller at the height of andrew miller
left on left
cubs wiping away a 108-year championship
drop and schwarber was a big part of it
dayton's ahead 02. and he puts him away
big pitch from grant dayton
three great curveballs back to back to
back i mean known for elevating the
heater and getting the curveball off it
i mean just present themselves right
over the heart of the plate entice look
at that i mean look at the depth on that
thing
sees it recognizes it she's got too much
spin bottom
big second out
now eight hitter victor robles
one b player of the game victor
now's your chance he had a shot
yesterday you can keep this thing going
for ryan zimmerman who loves left-handed
pitching
and there's a three-batter minimum rule
too so dayton's facing zimmerman if
robles can keep it going
[Applause]
walk a single and a flyout for from
robles this afternoon
here's castro and gomes
one run in for the nationals in the
eighth another strike from dayton this
time going with the heater and they say
b to bro place
[Applause]
do you drop the 12-6
let's rush him upstairs first okay
jeff mathis sets up high
good call
roblaise lays off i didn't like that go
back up there again that was too
non-competitive grant
get right back up there again you'll get
a fish if not then you go to the
breaking ball
the braves with a three run fourth
nationals with a point in the fourth
and this eighth inning
josh harrison the lead-off double he
comes around to score thanks to john
gomes now victor robles does not go
after that one
you saw it too see the take
kind of a juan soto take he wanted to do
a shimmy on that one
he's trying to be more like
juan soto and rightfully so
no place more patient
this season
[Applause]
a two two
he has widened his stance with two
strikes this season just like soto does
walk percentage up big
really take one for zimmerman or is it
in the zone it's in there he fouls it
off
[Applause]
[Applause]
huge hack right there he's on both
pitches and dayton's not fooling anybody
he's going high heater or breaking ball
he's got to throw the breaking ball for
a strike right here
zimmerman on death i'm throwing it below
the zone
see if he bites
oh what
[Applause]
and victor robles is down on strikes
[Music]
i mean that is a pro take right there
you have to get ejected right here
that's what has to happen you might get
kicked out no it's part of it yeah
that's the pitch we'll look back on
[Applause]
he knows he missed it he knows
that would have loaded up the bases
for mr national ryan zimmerman
wow
well grand dayton tried to get victor
robles to chase no wow what that pitch
it's a bit downstairs
let's see
one run for the nats in the eighth one
run game
[Applause]
there it goes
game winner
see
you
later
oh my goodness
112 miles an hour
463 feet carla schwarber
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's why you don't bunt apparently
right not with this guy
one ball two strikes two out nobody on
top of the knife
scherzer's into the wind-up the kick and
the one-two pitch
[Applause]
it is a complete game victory the 12th
of his career and the nationals out of
the dugout to congratulate max scherzer
[Applause]
we've reached the ninth and we're still
thinking about that pitch that ended the
eighth victor robles with a great take
two on for the nationals down a run they
scored one in the eighth brat hand in
the ninth right now
for the gnats
i mean credit to the advancement of
victor robles as a hitter with his pitch
recognition
but you don't get rewarded on that one
walk would have loaded up the bases for
ryan zimmerman that one is skied by
albie's
josh bell in foul ground
there's one
[Music]
i mean listen the umpires behind home
plate are doing the best they can i
completely understand that but therein
lies the frustration right
you're grinding so hard to play you're
in a huge spot in the game a chance to
be the hero goat whatever
seeing the ball
take grand d date in full
and have the about ripped from you
that's tough
he doesn't seem to be that bothered by
it he's looking at his cuticles
[Laughter]
manny after the game petty
zuna takes a strike here it is
with the box
oh the box caught it see the box is
going to catch that pitch
not where it lands but where it comes
across but falls down that falls down
it's not even close actually
but what are you going to do it's a
great presentation by the way
you got a nail hanging what are you
going to do
great presentation behind the plate
you saw him get schwarber earlier in the
inning on three straight curveballs that
that were out of his own very similar
pitches so obviously it's showing itself
to be a strike for about 59.5 feet
ozuna doubled and scored in the fourth
and
little
swing he wants back
over to first to complete the k
[Applause]
swinging through the water there
you know with the reception yeah
the last one to score for atlanta too
since the fourth they scored three
great slide in the home yeah
brad hand
going back to last year 16 for 16 and
saved in 2020 205 era
that slider is what he's known for
there's funky his head flies out kind of
deceptive
short leg kick kind of shoulders
everything coming at you at once ability
to spin the ball a couple different ways
you see you get marcelo zuna he's
swinging it back good i know he's been
struggling last two three nights he's
been swinging him back good he just
swung at one that bounced
kind of under his back foot
[Applause]
hand had an option last year that was
declined by cleveland's
it took a while for him to find a home
but
signs for 10 and a half million with
washington they have their ninth inning
man
they got good options with daniel hudson
[Applause]
you got him bread hand you got mr tanner
rainey coming in you got you got weapons
where i think where i feel like atlanta
will smith i get it he's your closer
i think if we're in the trust tree you'd
like to be able to use will smith high
leverage like they did last year and
have that malanson on the back end they
don't have that weaponry
in their bullpen that
brian snicker had last year
[Applause]
riley
chopper for harrison
played it well on that hop
rat hands looks really strong so far in
2021 does his job in the top of the
ninth last licks for the nationals they
need a run to keep this thing going
marlene koenig would like to say welcome
to the gnats and wants to know how you
will get involved in the nats community
i do have my own charity it's called
schwarber's neighborhood heroes my
sister served in the military and now
she's a policeman my dad worked at so we
uh serve police fire military we want to
shine light on good i'm definitely
really excited to go out in the
community that was definitely one of the
highlights of uh my career so far was
being able to go and participate in the
home run derby especially nats park i
think that may still be the best home
run derby that they've ever had i'm
enjoying the moment i was enjoying the
stadium i was enjoying the fans it was
definitely a fun show to be at and the
crowd is really getting into it these
nats fans are loving kyle schwarber
right now carol in manassas virginia
wants to know how your dugout dancing is
when i was in chicago they they kind of
blow it up i was in show choir that was
a lot of singing and dancing a lot of
spirit fingers i love to keep the energy
high in the dugout any kind of dancing
is good for me so i'm i'm ready
[Applause]
good one today in d.c
one run of fair bottom nine nats with
nine one and two due up in their order
so we'll see trey turner on deck
will smith time picked up his sixth save
of the season last night in the w for
atlanta
they've grabbed the first two games of
this series they've taken four or five
from the gnats all in dc so far this
year
that's a lefty which is just the way
ryan zimmerman likes it
he's had a really good year so far he's
swinging the bat well in spring training
he carries it right over into 2021 so
much so that
he's been
by far out producing josh bell yeah he's
been crafty at the dish no doubt ryan
ryan's got a lot of moving parts he's
got big leg kick a lot of things have to
sync up but usually takes him a little
bit to get rolling
with his timing is right this is one of
the better hitters i mean go look at the
back of the baseball card watched him
the other day against the marlins facing
trevor rogers who's a
big time problem from the left side with
the marlins got him down 02 and tried to
sneak him
heat her in
ryan took him three-run bomb dead center
that ended up being the biggest blow in
the game so
a smart hitter a productive hitter
throughout his career and he wants that
one back yeah
just setting them up for it late
some do
not many
i only saw one player do that who jim
edmonds was the only one who really
would tell me on deck i'm going to swing
it a curveball in the dirt look like a
fool i'll get it again and i'm going to
take it deep that's awesome
zimmerman rips one to left field and
he's got extra paces
ryan zimmerman with a pinch hit double
to start off the last of the ninth
it's a perfect day now you pinch run
he hits the showers
one for one with a dove
he's looking davey
[Applause]
that slider catches a lot of the plate
and zimmerman's all over it he hits the
ball
there it is have a good one ryan andrew
stevenson's got a few more feet on you
with his sprint speed
[Applause]
he's coming into the dugout that's how
it's done boys
you could have been hitting him in the
eighth
after robles was called on strikes
it would have been zimmerman
with the bags full of gnats
zimmerman
out stevenson in turner up
taking a strike
[Applause]
nats are two games under 500
braves are two games below 500.
and at least has talent but no team has
separated itself yet
[Applause]
and i know there's people at home right
now screaming at the tv saying like trey
turner right here here's an opportunity
to push something down the right first
base line get the guy to third he's been
your best hitter all year you have to
trust in the fact that he's able to do
it swinging the bat move the runner
maybe gap one and tie it up
and he goes to right
nice piece
there and stevenson's gonna tag
so he still does what you need to do
absolutely
now a fly ball deep enough from
hernandez would bring in a run to tie
this game up high fives for trey turner
in the dugout
[Music]
one of the biggest at-bats of his life
right now yadiel hernandez a long
journey to get to this spot in the major
leagues
33 years old
big time numbers
in cuba as a youngster
[Applause]
smith fools in for strike one
[Music]
and harrison's on deck
[Music]
two hits today for josh
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's the beauty will smith you know
he's going to bury a slider right there
jeff mathis new addition to the braves
will trust him he knows the pedigree
he's willing to bury it with a man on
third knowing no balls get back behind
him
bill smith
out of newman georgia in the atlanta
area
[Applause]
grew up watching the braves
31 year old lefty missed in
[Applause]
this is the sac fly line
that's where you need to go
[Applause]
[Music]
past the green line should score the run
we're really testing marcelo zuna
[Applause]
since the shoulder injury the arm
strength yep it's not the same
and the braves will tell you it's not
even close it's like he went to st louis
a couple years ago and
it was damaged goods for them the entire
season and just never gotten right i
remember once or twice he handed the
ball off to an outfielder to make a
bigger throw if someone was close by
comes your power slider right here
42 sliders from smith we'll see if he
goes
and he got him
[Applause]
big pitch from will smith to retire
yadiel hernandez
[Music]
it's crazy this isn't even one of his
good ones right here but he could almost
told
mr hernandez he was throwing that pitch
right there
batters are over 18 with 13 punch outs
versus this slider slider this season
[Music]
that's why he signed up for the big
bucks three years 40 million
signed november in 2019
josh harrison
with a chance here against smith
[Applause]
got to give some credit to jeff mathis
today it's been great
calling a great game for drew smiley
making some big stops it's going to take
four days off and be back in there next
time
drew's on the mound
[Applause]
like every ball is
tripling away
a lot of movement from will smith
there's a line for harrison
one for six against the braves lefty
stevenson at third
knots down a run
and harrison connects to right
and acuna is there game over
the braves sweep the nationals
and up their record to 15 and 16 on the
year
it's the first time this season they win
a game with their new addition drew
smiley on the mound and he was
sensational
ozuna with a big slide it ended up being
the difference
here's your poll question we needed to
wait because we need to see how this one
went youtube player of the game azuna
smiley adrianza
or luke jackson
help us out d-ro
i'm lean and drew smiley right now it's
either adrianza or smiley
and we'll find out
as we have hit post game time
right here on youtube
it is the post game show presented by
global citizen backs live scott braun
mark derosa and savannah mccann
and we have 30 minutes dedicated to this
one a good one between the nationals and
the braves braves win by a run
adrianza knocked in two ozuna had the
big slide scored the run that proved to
be the difference
as atlanta sweeps the washington
nationals
they've grabbed five of six
youtube player of the game results
coming very soon right here
so if you're atlanta you've been through
some ups and downs they had a tough
series in dunedin against the toronto
blue jays including a loss for smiley
and look at them now winning three in a
row against the nationals they have to
feel good
the two left-handers max freed showing
out yesterday and drew smiley who
hopefully we're going to get a chance to
talk to in the next couple of seconds
here going out today
six innings of work four punch outs just
kind of right in the ship and given
everybody freddie got a day off his feet
and they won a ball game everybody take
a deep breath in atlanta
first win for drew smiley since
september 7th of 2019 here we are we're
with you and we did not plan the attire
like this because if if you saw us even
closer we have the same little designs
here going the whole thing wardrobe they
hook us up here but anyway we're live
with you for the next 30. scott braun
mark derosa this was good good clean fun
this afternoon
excellent defensive plays in center
field some really tight pitches
home plate um nick marley had a job to
do not easy nowadays with the way that
the ball spins and the velocity coming
at you but you know nats fans are gonna
think about the pitch that was called
for strike three for victor robles they
should think about it and i'm getting a
lot of people in my mentions telling me
austin reilly strike three was the same
exact pitch i i completely disagree with
that tough spot
means a breaking ball at the bottom of
the zone that grant dayton struck out
schwarber on three of them he doubled
down against robles executed a pitch
just a nice clean tight ball game both
lefties threw the ball great i thought
lester was good for the gnats
on the flip side drew smiley definitely
with him and max reid that that has to
calm down their rotation a little bit
yeah drew smiley was the big signing in
the off season along with charlie morton
to be fair the braves always do this
alex antopolis their gm has talked about
it
i don't have a plan b they are
aggressive after the free agents that
they want to sign and then they come
through quite often we've seen it for
the last three or four years with the
guy that they want they did it early a
few years back with josh donaldson this
offseason they said more in smiley sign
them up quickly i i think it's
interesting to watch them they trust a
lot of their homegrown talent rightfully
so and then they kind of nickel and dime
with the with the one-year deals like
you said the donation the ozuna the
hamels the drew smiley so for the 4 for
56 or 4 for 63 that ozuna got that was
kind of stepping out for them because i
i do believe in a world of no universal
dh who have they really bidding against
i think it screams more to the fact that
what ozuna meant to their team in 2020
not only hitting behind freddy with the
18 homers but how
how loved he is in the clubhouse with
the albies and the acunas and uh and all
that latin american persuasion in that
clubhouse it's so huge they have like
the freddie freeman and the ozuna it's
like the perfect
combination of leadership yeah he
brought so much fun to the team last
year and azuna signed up maybe next year
the ditch is back anyway in the national
league but for now
pitchers hit
and there was not much hitting going on
for a while for the nationals because
drew smiley had it going and the defense
behind him was solid as well
look at swanson sky up
and come down to turn the double play
so drew smiley picks up the w for the
atlanta braves big smile joins us live
for a global audience on youtube right
now drew thanks for the time how are you
today and congrats on the win
i'm good man thank you guys uh
anytime you go in a major league game it
feels pretty good so glad to get going
it's been a rough start to the season
for me personally but
still a lot of work to be done a lot of
season to be played and looking forward
to it hey drew the poll results just
came in you are the youtube player of
the game
custom trophy it's gonna have your name
on it we do this every week can you hold
it up for us do you have it oh he's got
oh there it is let's see the play button
the whole thing where are you putting
that
pretty cool i'll put it right there in
my uh
this might be my first trophy so i'm
gonna have to make a trophy case it's
nice it'll have your name on it
delivered later this week with the
engraving great job well done drew take
me through it did you tell everybody did
you tell everybody hey calm down relax
i'm gonna figure this out i'm gonna get
it right what was working for you today
um you know honestly it was kind of a
bit of a grind today my fastball i had a
really good life on my fastball that was
my best pitch the curveball it was it
was one of those games where i had it
going early i had two quick strikeouts
on it and then it kind of disappeared
for the middle innings of the game and
was kind of yanking it down for balls
wasn't really uh being aggressive with
it
and then
in the final third time through the
lineup the fifth in the fifth and sixth
it really started i really started
dropping it in for strikes and uh
burying it when i needed to so that was
the key that's always been the key for
me is is drop the curveball in early and
then make him chase later on and have
good fastball commands so
that's where that's when i'm at my best
um
this season has just kind of been like a
few things going my going against me
every game and and you know how baseball
is it can kind of spiral on you quick
but
but like i said it's a really long
season and and i know i'm capable of
getting these guys out every five days
i've been doing it for a little while
now and um
anytime like i said when you get a win
and and you you can help the team out
and and celebrate with your guys it's a
good feeling you have to be fired up i
was telling scotty braun
i i've been in a box against you i know
it's eight to ten years ago but this
guy's heater plays up
has that always been kind of your mantra
your heater you get swing and miss on
your fastball i i i mean are you aware
of the late life on your fastball
oh yeah absolutely i mean my mindset
every game is attack you know
make the hitters be in defense mode and
go right at them i don't want to nibble
you know i want to i i'm prone to give
up a few fly balls here or home run
balls here and there when the hitters
run into it but that's okay that's just
that's the way the league is right now
um the key is to not do it when there's
guys on base and and and get ahead get
ahead stay ahead so that's my mantra
every game is get ahead stay ahead
attack keep these guys on their toes and
then mix mix in the curveball and cutter
from there what was it like to work with
jeff mathis today was this your first
time ever working with him in a regular
season game
no actually uh i was in texas with him
in 2019 so i got a little bit of history
with him and uh math is i mean i call
him captain he's he's the guy
he's been around for 14 15 years in the
league now um he knows how to catch he
knows how to how to work with what the
pitcher has that day with the scouting
report of the hitters he knows how to
navigate through a lineup and uh when
he's back there you feel really
comfortable
what's it like working with this front
office too with atlanta i know they've
brought some pictures over it they also
and we talked about this early on in off
seasons they have a few players that
they pick and they target and they often
come through with josh donaldson and
marcel ozuna on the hitting side this
year it was you and charlie morgan so
what did that mean to you and did they
have something for you when you came to
the table
oh i mean it it it just uh brings
confidence to you i mean when they seek
you out right when the off season starts
and say you you're you're their guy
um
it just makes you feel good you know a
lot of teams these days they kind of
slow play it and wait around and brave
said no i mean you and charlie those are
the guys we want and we want to gus i
mean charlie
his career has been amazing um it's one
that i like to kind of look after how he
got off to a semi slow start and over
the past five six years he's been one of
the best pitchers in the league he's
really turned the corner and that's
that's what alex kind of told me when he
signed me as he kind of sees me in the
same shoes that i battled some injuries
and you know i've bounced around a few
times but when i'm at my best i know i
can get all these guys out on a regular
basis so for me it's just the
consistency
continuing to work every five days
work on the craft you know throw strikes
and and mix speeds and it sounds easy
but when you get out there on the mound
you guys know it's it's a little harder
than it looks
i want to ask you i mean you you guys
have to feel relaxed now you watched you
sat there yesterday and watch max free
go to work and then you back it up on on
the back end is there anything that two
of you
can kind of bounce ideas off each other
something you could give him something
he could maybe you take you take from
him
yeah for sure i mean free's a bulldog if
um honestly that's that's what i've got
out of him since spring training is he
is laser focused every day from the
second he gets to the field to not so
we're a little bit different
personalities than that as in you know
i'm kind of loose and and and just
vibing trying to have a good time and uh
freeze he's locked in he's he's go time
ready to go to war any day you know even
when he's in the batter's box he's not
taking a pitch off and uh so so i think
i need a little bit of that honestly but
um all of us we got great relationships
charlie you know he's the
he's the guy that's been around been
doing it two world series appearances he
he's he's seen it all so we all kind of
bounce ideas off him um ian anderson
that guy's way above his
his ears um
he's incredible he's gonna be really
really good um
so the whole staff really i mean you
know what can you say about that guy
he's a beast
yeah it's it's fun so every every day
you're watching these guys play and it's
everybody like all right let me go try
to one-up him one-up him so it's nice to
kind of get in the winning circle with
these guys yeah you followed up freed
really well drew congratulations on the
w today and good luck the rest of the
way we'll talk to you soon
all right thanks guys i appreciate it
youtube there it is there it is
youtube player of the game
drew smiley joining us
on youtube 44
he edges marcelazuna for that trophy
telling you custom design you would have
liked that
absolutely yeah
it's unique and youtube's cool i mean
you would bring that home kids would be
all over it drew smiley showing off the
trophy and a big smile a lot of
confidence in the interview we'll get
into it on the other side of this
braves win 3-2
[Music]
what did the baby corn ask his mom corn
where's my popcorn
i'm gonna win this game
how did the hipster burn his mouth
i don't know he ate the pizza before it
was cool
i can't look at your face and not laugh
is that a good thing or a bad thing
i mean for this game it's a good thing
or a bad thing for me all right
what did the big flower say to the tiny
flower
you're small
hey there bud
there's no way i should he should get a
point from me laughing at his laugh
what do you call it when batman skips
church
robin christian bale
why does snoop dogg always carry an
umbrella
because he doesn't want it to rain for
drizzle
it's not i'm not laughing at the joke
i'm not laughing at what you did
brave sweep in dc game of the week post
game show presented by global citizen
vaxx live and to see how it all happened
we show you this
start off the fourth inning for atlanta
runs the slugs
he sends one the left and we'll get to
watch him run the bases ronaldo jr
starts off the fourth with a base hit
111 miles an hour off the bat for that
single
there he goes wide dolby's the throw
skips away into center
and acuna is off to third
and just like that one of the flashiest
players in the game is 90 feet away from
scoring the game's first run he does not
like to throw over the first base you
got a guy like ronald acuna who's got
wheels for days he can go first move
even if he does throw that to josh bell
i still think he beats the transfer
second he's playing youth ball let me
take it on the third base once he sees
josh harrison miss this full boat
he missed
first two hitters at the frame on board
for atlanta runners on the corners that
brings us to ozuna
mr grand slam from yesterday mizuna into
the corner and that's going to score the
first run of the day ronald lucuna
junior will trot home and marcelazuna
knocks in a run for atlanta it's one zip
cutter inside from john lester's it's
actually a great pitch
great pitch marcelo zuna almost knows he
wants to go to that well to get him to
roll over to third for a double play
kind of cheats to the spot
keeps it fair
one nothing bravo's first right now
second and third they are set up for a
big inning
sent to center and that's going to fall
and score at least one for atlanta
second on its way edward slide of zunits
in there
andreyanza scores two for the braves
making three nothing
as all bees and azuna come home
one on two outs it's kyle schwarber
schwarber rips one into the corner
and that's a base in second third here
we
and everything's gonna come go it's
bobbled in the corner josh bell's gonna
score as the match break the ice
schwarber ends up at third and it's
three to one
[Music]
solid contact to center hanging in the
air and look who's all over it
victor robles wow both center fielders
today putting on a show
look at roleplay's move
[Applause]
made that play look easy
[Music]
drama in the late stages let's start
with kyle schwarber leading off a nine
pitch walk
that would be it for drew smiley who was
brilliant went to the fastball early and
often luke jackson in victor robles
greets him with a base hit and then dave
martinez turns to juan soto here d-ro
yeah and in a 2-0 count count leverage
knew he had to throw a heater
just a nice play luke jackson came in he
had some tough match-ups in this inning
and he was able to wiggle out of it
tough day for trey turner and over five
and then makes a big pitch to mr
hernandez to get out keeps this a
two-run game now let's fast forward to
the bottom of the eighth where josh
harrison leads up with an extra base hit
that was almost gone
i mean can you get much closer
and you had to go for the tall part in
right center fields
so after a castro walk and a bell fly
out john gomes says come on down it's a
one-run game
edgar santana out grand dayton in kyle
schwarber down on strikes and then
victor robles patient that's a good take
that's a great take right there
cannot be a strike at the big league
level
right there cannot be
it would have been ryan zimmerman with
the bases basically exploded
and
zim is hot right now at the plate he
loves left-handed pitching he showed it
off in the next inning but they said oh
we could have used that in the eighth
instead the pinch hit double leads to
stevenson as the pinch runner trey
turner would fly out to right field
stevenson moves up to third so hey
you'll take this runner a third less
than two outs you gotta convert
this is the battery well will smith is
tough right here yeah like you said left
on left tough tough matchup
gets him with the slider and josh
harrison he throws him a backdoor
curveball josh is on everything right
now and lines out to ronaldo
that's how the braves win today by a run
and sweep the series against the
washington nationals now just
one game under the 500 mark while the
nats are three games below 500 super
competitive division nobody off to a
sizzling start in the n at least so it's
still anyone
up for grabs in the nl's braves win it
3-2 savannah mccann at the ballpark
savannah what did you see today
well you know the brave skipper has said
that the way drew smiley was pitching
was kind of synonymous with how his
whole braves team has been doing a slow
start to the season but a really hot
spring and once drew smiley got going he
knew that this team was really gonna
have a starting rotation again and you
know drew smiley did not disappoint in
this game he tossed the most fastballs
he has since 2016 and that's what really
got the braves their first sweep of the
nat since 2014. the braves are on a
three-game winning streak where they're
gonna head over to the analyst foes in
the phillies at home where the knots are
gonna take on the yankees in the bronx
all right savannah thank you very much
still jealous that she's at the park
we're hanging here we'll be there soon
though first four starts for drew smiley
not pretty 21 runs in 19 innings
homeritus nine homers allowed highest
home run rate in baseball and then he
shows up today and looks like the guy
they were going yeah and scotty he went
to that fourth seemed well time and time
again he talked about having his
curveball in the first two i'm always
enamored that's why i asked max scherzer
that always enamored how guys can have a
pitched and lose it in the middle
portions of the innings and then re get
recapture it again but he's always had
that heater that plays up he's gonna
give up the occasional home run ball but
the way the shadows were at four o'clock
today
he could kind of him and lester just
went to mr lester just went to work at
the bottom half of that zone with the
heater curveball combination slicing and
dicing and getting some favorable calls
here and there if you were on the mound
this afternoon that's true no doubt and
hey that's frustrating but we know we
saw some of those hats the gnats had
their opportunities in some matchups
that i don't think they necessarily
would have let's say in a postseason
game or down the stretch in september i
mean you had a situation where you got
juan soto to the plate in a 2-0 count
first and second against luke jackson it
doesn't get any more favorable
than that situation for the gnats and
soda's going to be back every day for
the nationals soon he'll be hitting on a
regular basis starting this weekend
because they have the opportunity for a
dh and that's just fishing for w's they
didn't find one today
much more on the post game show
presented by global citizen backslide
next
if cows don't have internet
how do they order things
doordash
from a catalog
that's good that's good
which state has really small soft drinks
i don't know
[Music]
minnesota
got a chance to clinch our third
straight nl's tonight get the job done
[Applause]
they might have picked that ball up on
the radar along with the plane bombs
away in atlanta ga the braves have hit
three more home runs tonight you're
looking for fire power you've come to
the right place the braves are pounding
the marlins 11-1
for the braves they're the champions of
the east in 2020.
braves three nationals too it's the post
game show presented by global citizen
facts live and that show
is on saturday night eight o'clock
eastern we had a show personally for us
it was called the josh harrison miked up
show all day long
hey that's for my boy bogey two hands i
didn't drop a couple pop-ups bogey got
me right
what's going on nick jeff what's up baby
how are you doing good you
sean rodriguez to this day say you're
the most athletic catcher he's ever
played with
i'm mic'd up
so if you want to speak you want to say
hi to youtube say hi hello youtube
guys what's up baby
you mic'd up too no i thought they said
you were i am so
all right
we're the same size i'm right with you
[Music]
i thought i got him the ball kind of the
ball kind of was like a change up but
but anytime that throw up the line you
know we can get together yeah it was up
the line just a little bit
oh boy that ball came out like a
changeup huh yeah no i know
the perfect throw though just bare tad
right there
that bad boy went way farther than i
thought it was like right there
that could have been bad right there
yeah i mean going to pick it i called it
shin
but it could have been his acl
i ain't got no pop
i ain't got no pop
that's gone probably at like 27 other
parks
tell you where it ain't going here in
detroit
he might need to be miked up every game
two hits hitting everything on the
screws and then even that in-depth
analysis we're looking for on the call
of the game victor roble has taken
strike three many would say below the
zone josh harrison what did you
think no
no
come on
wow
so you disagree oh my gosh
that's passion he's been playing for a
while you know this is early may
baseball nat's in a fight for the
division he's been great 329 six extra
base hits
on base percentage you're over 400 i
mean you're a star to get on base over
40 percent of the time i get it it's
early
almost as many walks as strikeouts and
then you know adding to the tools that
he brings to the table he can talk he's
entertaining he's fun to listen to he's
got a future you know with the
microphone if he wants one after he
plays but that call that we saw in the
eighth inning that was you know maybe
the play of the game the pitch of the
game to get that reaction and see it
from josh harrison that's the good stuff
no that i mean you're battling every day
there's not a single big leaguer you
fight the one thing you tell yourself
you tell yourself two things as a
position player coming into the season i
want to stay healthy
and i don't want to give away one at-bat
i don't want to give away one so to have
it taken from you in a big spot against
a divisional foe
you see the reaction stuff it's tough to
swallow how would you have reacted to
that
the pg version yeah the pg version i
mean i'm probably have to get ejected
from that game i mean that ball's on the
ground i mean people are saying that
that pitch is similar to the austin
riley pitch it's not even close to the
same pitch that ball is a curveball
spinning down i don't care where it
crosses the presentation of that pitch
right there that ball's below the zone
and we've got something special we're
bringing to the post game show starting
today it's called curious creators
here's one from healy6 fun fact about
lester and derosa mark was five for 19.
two doubles in a homer lester kate him
four times these two have played golf
together and i'm sure
honestly uh you know truth be told i
spend a lot of time with johnny lives in
the atlanta area i don't think people
really truly realize that
lived there for a long time and uh
i mean not too different from what he
what he featured today just maybe about
three or four miles an hour faster
exactly but still hey we're seeing it
he's 37 years old
picking his spots command is there looks
like he can be a serviceable number four
starter no doubt he gets half the league
out by the name running out to the
mountain yeah lester i know who he is
yeah durability knots need innings two
strasberg's hurt right now looks like
he's making his way back simulated game
today 35 pitches two innings what else
is going on around major league baseball
hey nobody watches the game like mark
derosa every single night you are locked
mr means
means to an end right here fastball
change-up combination he was awesome hey
happy birthday willie mays turns 90
years old today
and
albert pujols cut by the end i need to
dive into this i saw this as we were
coming on the air give me your quick
take my quick take is how do you release
one of the greatest players regardless
i'm not saying he doesn't deserve maybe
not to be on on the roster anymore it's
the way they're doing it
let me present to scenarios one of the
greatest players of all time doesn't he
get to decide the way he goes out so
that's what i'm saying there's more to
this okay i'm albert i come to you
you're the gm whoever someone that's
making a decision
i want out because i want to see if i
can play somewhere else i i think i
might already have here left okay i
understand that and i'll honor that and
i do believe that jared walsh and otani
are going to steal most of your at-bats
this year so i understand that we've
also given you 10 years 240 million so
let's do this the right way
let's cooler heads prevail
we'll take you out of tonight's lineup
if you were ever in there
and let's sit down let's sit down let's
not be brash and say
we're gonna designate you for assignment
now the whole world's wondering how
come on
come on look at these numbers this is a
legend you know
you don't get to just designate this
10-time all-star angels have no playoff
w's with pujols
mike trapp that's on their mind every
single day angels fans thinking about it
and jared walsh is a good-looking player
should be in there every day at first
base yeah no one's denying the fact that
albert's lost a step i i i mean no one's
denying the fact that maybe there's some
different options on the angels that can
provide them more of a chance on the
offensive side i'm just saying what
alberts meant to the game of baseball
this was bizarre to me the way it's
being
portrayed again
i'm i'm gonna get into it yeah i know
he's on mlb network every day i can't
wait to watch you uh tomorrow morning
last thing before we get off here um
does he play again for another team yeah
someone does yeah he does yeah honestly
if he's going in there raising kane
about wanting to be in the lineup
you know i can think of
i mean i just think guys like that get
should be able to go out on their own
terms whether that's
with tony larussa in chicago whether
that's back to st louis for a farewell
tour i don't know what it is but i know
what alberts meant to the game and how
great he is i mean
miggy albert manny i know i'm gonna
leave a few out like of my generation
coming up
he might be the best he was the guy
did you have fun did you enjoy this
today we loved having you thank you can
you come back sometime i would love to
good
mark derosa superstar utility man
versatility he can do it all we'll just
do this again yeah josh harrison was
awesome game of the week live on youtube
back on the same day next week thursday
may 13th nl central clash cardinals
brewers coverage begins with our
pre-game show 12 30 eastern we'll see
you then he's big he's strong mark
derosa bringing it today the great
savannah mccann our entire superstar
crew i'm scott braun logging out for now
see you next time on youtube
oh um
[Music]
[Music]
so
you